foreign
I feel sorry for you because this is a
visual you don't want to miss yeah we
this is a real pp's Playhouse over here
yeah it is Tammy's birthday today and we
are we pulled out all the stops
everybody say happy birthday to me happy
birthday thank you
Tammy thank you it is my birthday and
birthday speech speech okay well all
right well uh I walked in here
expecting not much
yeah
but I'm blown away and I just want to
say I've never gotten balloons before
that weren't the round normal ones like
these are the expensive ones these are
the ones that you know I'm talking about
just the regular the ones you have to
love yourself yeah yeah I've only gotten
those so when I walked in and I saw
these and I knew they were for me
because it's no one else's birthday is
this the first time you've ever seen
condoms not blown up as a balloon
yeah kind of the only thing condoms are
good for at this point yeah nobody uses
condoms anymore nobody how the hell did
those candles get lit were they always
lit and I got a birthday cake you guys
if you are listening and not watching
I've got a birthday cake right in front
of me and it's got
non-candles I'm a bit older than that
but that's fine so let's have you blot
the candles okay but you you can only
make a wish if you tell us the wish
happy birthday I wish for can it be well
you know what I'm wishing for uh take a
guess uh
um I am uh okay let me guess hold on
let's all guess Tammy's birthday wish
dick
yeah dick what else would it be well
okay you have to specify what kind of
deck you don't know what the universe is
gonna give you at this point I'll take
just about anything okay anything you
know it's been a few days so I'm really
foaming at the mouth so I was thinking
in honor of your birthday and in honor
of our 100th episode of our podcast here
uh we would like to do a couple mukbangs
in your honor with you
the good news is the first round of
things are in the shape of dicks
we have uh a panoply
of hot dogs from Dog House okay do you
know about dog house it's a restaurant
in La that has the most gourmet hot dogs
around whoa and I'm gonna let you choose
the one we start with I'm first gonna
tell the audience and honor the 100th
episode we are completely trashing the
rule that we're not going to eat on
camera whoa I know this is y'all's worst
nightmare but it's gonna be sexual I
promise we're gonna go smooth we're
gonna really cradle you in it's gonna be
slow and intimate you're gonna try to
not be too juicy I'm not gonna try to
open wrappers I know you guys freak out
when we chew stuff but this is I mean
it's just life it's Tammy they'll get
over it it's Tammy let's get over it and
when you're done jerking off to it
that's when you're gonna be like oh this
is annoying exactly one thing else I
will say because I've already had let me
just be honest I did already have a
couple shots of vodka and it is
affecting my performance and I would
like to just say that right now here's a
couple things that I want to make sure
y'all don't forget we have some mukbangs
with sodas should those come out now
how do you like to bang your mucks I'd
like a soda you would like a soda it's
always let's get some of these sodas the
ones that are deliciously flavored a lot
of different tastes I see a bottle that
says Cactus Cooler on it yeah you know
about Cactus Cooler
I've never heard of a Cactus Cooler
but it looks cool get out right now
you've never fucked with a Cactus Cooler
let's get a little
she only had a Tang
Cactus Cooler honey can we get her a
glass oh you got you know you've got
your big glass I got you this question
okay
can I just real quick uh whose Crown is
that that is uh for uh you Tammy to wear
because you're the birthday girl
oh my gosh an angel
does it look good yes
okay the only thing annoying about it is
it kind of distracts me from your tits
momentarily but then I go right back
okay
if you need me to well we might get
there we might get there at some point
tonight bacon
bacon let me try the Cactus Cooler real
quick
here we go you got this Cactus Cooler
you got this you got this Cactus Cooler
um
[Music]
that's good what does it taste like
a little bit like cactus
that's been cooled down
okay yeah it knew the assignment it
delivered in your fancy birthday cup
that's good can I try
ranch dressing soda hmm
and then bacon
what's going on in there are you praying
are you just regrouping I'm nervous
about the range dressing okay yeah yeah
because I never had that before because
there's a chance it might not taste like
ranch dressing and that would be a
disappointment well there's a chance it
probably will that's what I'm scared of
and then what'll happen
let's find out
no oh not enough not enough to get it
not enough to get the taste buds engaged
it tastes like cream soda that's gone
bad
it really does
it really does really cream soda that's
gone bad I don't like a soda that has a
yellow pepper on the sticker or a tomato
or that says ranch dressing
yeah sometimes that throws you off
I want to try that one oh
oh you just saw her reaction and said I
want to try that oh that that tastes
like old balls old balls oh that's a
bummer what did you taste there
movies either popcorn really
yeah oh baking soda honey but a fun guy
he's bad is this what it looks like when
you come
worse
I don't know it was a very good sell
what you just did
go ahead bacon soda go ahead
it tastes like Dr Pepper to me which is
my favorite drink let me try
you're fucking insane
your taste buds don't work I think that
I think the ranch dressing sort of broke
them I think I've sprained I sprained my
taste buds go ahead just smell it come
on okay
foreign
that's the worst thing I've ever put my
mouth you feel like we won
worst thing in your mouth yes yeah all
the things that been in your mouth dick
balls scrotums titties
queefs it does it that's how do you know
I've had a queef in there
no one it just once I just just once
that I have so here's the as we go
through this mukbang I'm gonna ask a lot
of questions from fans because they
really want to get granular on your sex
advice this is really going to turn into
100th episode of good for you slash
Tammy's sex advice now would you like to
choose a dog before we get started I'm
ready because I've been sitting here
smelling them okay okay good okay so
Benton's gonna come in and help us out
because we've got a hot chicken in
Nashville okay that is a good corn corn
dog that's a big corn dog that is a corn
dog it is a dog to Corn we've got an old
town which is smoked bacon wrapped dog
caramelized onions pickled jalapenos uh
Chipotle
cheese
okay corn dogs we've got what's that we
got the cowboy all right yep she's got
smoked bacon wrap dog cheddar cheese
sauce crispy fried onions and barbecue
sauce thoughts sounds like a winner it's
like a combo that Tammy would fuck with
I'd like to start with her oh um she's
ready you want me okay right away the
pots will sit on the tots okay all right
literally Paige will sit on the tops
later okay which one am I gonna do I'm
gonna do I might have the other one of
that okay this looks good okay can I
just say first off the bun looks buttery
it does look buttery it looks better and
soft which is what you're looking for
yes that's right and it's also like 30
minutes
into its existence that's fine okay that
don't matter it's jerky at this point
exactly okay you ready yes ma'am all
right I'm going in me too
that looks like an expensive Hot Dog
I've never seen three ridges like it's
an actual bun
um
oh wow there's levels to that ship
good dog
that's a thick pucker look is it
look at that fucking look at it I'm like
that's double the size of a um of a
regular like
National Hebrew or something like that
sure sure Oscar Mayer and so it is a
very meaty dog
this one's good
the cheese flavor is phenomenal you can
change that's real cheese you can tell
that it's real cheese but it kind of has
a
processed flavor which I love that added
a little yeah like yellow number five
yep which is what you really want on a
hot dog it's the best you do for you you
know what I mean you don't want sargenta
on your fucking hot dogs you don't I'm
telling you right you want craft neon
the cheese has to look at the color of
your Cactus Cooler yeah I'm gonna take
one more bite if it looks too natural
oh here we go
she's got that big deep throat energy
um
I was good it's got like a very sweet it
is great that was great
yeah that's fucking good yeah that's
fucking good we like crunch it's called
The Cowboy try it crispy onion crispy
onion on there gave her one onion what's
the crunch by the way this is the the
just FYI that uh Tammy's gotten so
famous that Paige just gets crumbs like
just feeds her like leftover crumbs and
I just get crumbed in here
yeah or you're little
you know she's comfortable yeah how has
this journey been uh for you and Tammy
oh it's been great yeah how did you meet
also are you okay and if you need help
just wink okay uh I don't know how to
wink but we're we're doing great we met
on um you tell them tell me we met on
Tinder you did not you did not no we've
been on Instagram okay um the new Tinder
frankly yeah yeah and
um
that's pretty much it we met in real
life and I was like damn this is a cool
bitch I have a question can you open
this coconut for me so I can put it in
my drink that goes there okay that goes
on top other way the sharp part and then
you're gonna hammer it in and you're
gonna get the coconut milk and the meat
out oh okay okay
Tammy is strong Tammy is not kidding
around put this down for a minute yeah
The Tiara might have to go for maybe
stand up for it feels like it needs a oh
there we go okay not kidding did you see
that splash of water yeah it's squirting
is that you squirting I am a smarter
your Kink is doing something for the
first time fifty percent of the time I'm
squirting I would like to talk about
that because I have questions look at
this look at that
foreign
any more chores any more coconuts I need
to open look at that beautiful coconut
water and look I'm just gonna pour it
right in to my drink
it's kind of like discharge
um
mate's pretty good okay I'm gonna try
this water okay
well how about a lemon meringue pie to
wash that one you know what I'll have
one of those yeah I bet that's really
good yeah yeah to wash down that I bet
that's really good okay we've got lemon
meringue okay
but look at the brand Melba's Fixins
that's a bad bitch I trust Melba dude
Melba had a business in the 20s a lemon
meringue soda business the bacon didn't
go over so well let's see what she got
here
fresh fresh tight
damn that's good damn that's good yeah
good nobody else getting drinking this
okay that's fair that's fair it's your
birthday this one's mine it's your
birthday have you had the apple pie
mm-hmm I ain't tried none of these I
didn't even know they
wait I think I like this oh no no I
think the bacon soda tastes like Boston
baked beans I like the tasting a Glade
plug-in huh why do you know what a Glade
plug-in smells like I ain't got a lot of
money but I got a lot of time
blade plugin
everything the bathroom smells it really
does Oh I thought it sounds like an
apple pie yep I've already been looking
I've locked the lemon one if I could
just put that set to that to the side
okay
what's your number one drink Tammy
number one Takes the Cake
um
I'd probably say Fireball or screwball
or uh what's it called uh course
I do like Keystone Light
um but if I'm talking alcohol I don't
fuck with tequila okay with vodka yeah
because I don't like the sensation of it
going down my throat okay do you have a
gag
it tastes like I'm drinking rub and
alcohol in honor of Tammy our show uh
Muse I'm gonna take one shot of Fireball
and the last time
okay let's all Cheetos here's two Honeys
a hundred episode
Honeys and my birthday
's birthday celebration here we go it
has only begun let the cholesterol build
ready oh God I last time I did a
h
I'm drunk we're drunk I don't know
yeah oh my God it's like those little
cinnamon hearts that you ate when you're
a kid on Valentine's Day you gotta feel
it in your chest in a minute who do you
eat too many what about the Red Hots can
we talk about your gag reflex yeah
because I gag when I brush my teeth is
that normal
um yeah I can't I do it if it's in the
morning when I first wake up but what's
the deal what is it what is it when you
die on purpose like you're trying no I
can't not so I watched a porn with James
Dean the other day
like James no James Dean the porn star
porn star you're watching it was a old
porn I'm just saying stay focused
everyone as I've been so focused this
entire time uh that they were doing
important and this guy was fucking this
girl in the neck and she wasn't gagging
at all just taking it well I've heard
that people get those little ball things
out just so they cannot gag like if I
put this down my throat for one second I
would yeah except sometimes I puke too
have you ever been sucking a dick and
gag on it and then you puke up what
you're eating not really because of the
deepness of the wiener but because of
the smell of the balls right like upside
down can you try to do it fair sorry oh
sorry what am I can I no I I'll if okay
if the 100th episode is me gagging on a
corn dog look by the way here's another
thing I'm gonna say to you my big
birthday present to you which now that
I'm thinking about it on a little
Fireball it's gonna sound like I'm an
asshole but I would like to volunteer
myself
to be in one of your only Tammy episodes
and not only that but today a couple
people including myself from the good
for you team will be auditioning for you
let's do it but let me try with this
so this is going to be the audition do
porn stars want a gag is the idea that
you want them to go and then have
something this is just my personal
opinion and this is just what I've known
from sucking dick my whole life is
awesome what age
but that's good to know they were
probably small dicks yeah if they were
teen dicks well
here's the thing
I really think and tell me if I'm wrong
that men
love
when you're gagging and choking on a
wiener now I know in the comments not
only that they like that when tears come
out so they want you to think their dick
makes them sad no they're like oh I have
a big dick did I make her cry
really I have allergies my dick made her
cry no dude it's just the pollen yeah
it's summer it's summer okay because the
idea is that their dick is so big that
it it made me cry because you can't
breathe but but I cry every time I have
sex how do you know it's from your dick
just that's what they like to believe
just let them believe it so do you so
gag reflex is a positive or negative
only Tammy she's running you're running
a porn Empire what are you positive
gagging is a positive in that case I'm
gonna book this yeah
I gag when I brush my teeth today
doesn't matter because I'll brush my
tongue because that's really where
halitosis comes comes from so if I brush
my tongue I'll like sometimes puke up
like food but then do you feel good
after do you think that makes your
breasts look better like do not you puke
yeah you know when you gag
I've done it I don't puke like shit
doesn't come up I go just the genome
that doesn't come out yeah food doesn't
come out
does not come out we I will be stunned
have you puked on the Dick hold on this
is too big I'm gonna all right corn dogs
going in going down you're not even
trying it's thick that's a thing
is it touching the back
Whitney let's see how far he got in here
guys look at my eyes watering crying
how'd I do she got about right there
yeah and that was like a deep jab look
at my eyes watering yeah were you trying
it got me right because I tried it no
it's an involuntary reflex it got you it
got her you go that's it yeah but do you
want your own no it's fine okay
in the eye again good to know and this
is called The Walrus
oh wow uh-huh when you have two dicks at
once
double penetration well I've had double
pin but I've never had triple pen and
that's that's all my sexual fantasy list
okay talk me through that
well it's a hole in the front hole in
the back hole in the mouth and I just
had hole in the front hole in the back
but everybody does that mouth to vagina
not butthole
yeah so triple pin he's doing you in the
butt doing you in the badge and then
doing your mouth as well
three guys not one we are gonna send you
home nothing Tower and a TED Talk we're
gonna send you home with these Tums
because I'm worried about your butt
cheers when you're getting sex in the
butt
that's all like if that's happening it's
there's no nothing else is happening
well I like to push my limits and see
how far I can go okay okay I really you
know how do you make sure there's no
accidents when you do that the the tush
tush
no like shit no poop is that what you're
talking about yeah I've heard I'm gonna
be honest with y'all I've heard of that
yeah I've just looked at my entire life
and I don't know what it is I've had it
dude really one time me and my
ex-boyfriend we did a
animal and uh so
I we get done and I just smell shit dude
and I'm like where the hell is it like
it's nowhere to be seen
and I'm searching for like hours finally
hours because I everywhere I go I smell
this shit
soon enough I uh reach back in my hair
here comes a little dingleberry
from the animal you shit in your own
hair no I don't know what happened like
I don't know if he touched his wee-wee
and then touched my head and then the
dingleberry formed like what happened
they got you yeah what happened it
basically I got got so so you shit on
your own head you shit on my own head
pretty much you're your own pigeon yep
damn
so that'll happen
you've had that happen
no I do know this is another question
all your questions are under this spicy
chicken sandwich listen let's answer
some questions okay that's what I always
do during the mukbang look The key is
for you having questions but you can see
how I got distracted by that
um as we move on to the next dog or tots
or cake or by the way we're gonna we're
Lubes we're doing a mukbang of tasting
Loops corn dogs
save some space save some space okay
because we're gonna get to that in a
second
um uh and what should we do tots let's
do the tots okay this one's got cheddar
cheese sauce okay
arugula
Tomatoes smoked bacon
[Laughter]
oh so there's no bud on this no these
are tots I thought I'd give you some
thoughts so I can ask you questions
okay I see what's going on when I give
you a dog anything garlic shaped I lose
you okay you get distracted you're right
I lose you I can compete with a phallic
shape your bacon okay one top but what
do you put on your top the bacon mine's
got bacon and cheese okay hold on who
would want arugula on a top what's this
lettuce arugula arugula
no no no time we don't do that that's a
big fucking no tomatoes are you fucking
with tomatoes I'll put a little bit
tomato in there okay I don't this one
does have cheese do you want my bedroom
sure have a top
um
good I didn't have a good experience
eating out that's good see the lettuce
would have ruined it ruined the lettuce
would have ruined it Lettuce on cheese
tots
sick
psychotic pickling no that pisses me off
honestly it's only in Los Angeles well a
lot of fans have sent in questions and
I've had a fireball and a couple of too
many shots as she deep throats that and
doesn't gag by some miracle I'm gonna
ask you what are the best sex positions
ranked these are your fans they're
asking you haven't been clear enough
about this you're not clear in your
YouTube videos you're big and they don't
like it
I should have been taking that bot hold
on what's that okay you shouldn't have
taken that back
all right
I'm gonna shoot drawstripe okay
best number one we ain't gotta act
stupid here no and say oh I like the the
Flying Tiger and the we that's no okay
doggy doggy is number one number one
you're in the dark position
because here's what I'm thinking if
you're if your face is down and your ass
is Up Wait hold on hold on I'm doing
doggy wrong your face is down well
elbow's face however you want to do it
as long as your ass is up but there's no
dog involved what are you talking about
you're thinking you're talking about
something else okay so doggy style I
thought you had to brace your your I
thought you had to be in a like a table
top
and I thought you had to shit in the
house
so you just go down and slam your face
down you take you're just over there
napping sometimes faces down sometimes
arms are just as long as your ass is up
how do you feel if he grabs your arms
and holds them behind you
my pussy's throbbing right now
that's the best a little aggressive like
he's riding you yeah removing you like
he has an amputee fantasy here's what
I'm thinking no if your ass is up and
your the front of your body is contorted
in whatever way you want it to be your
Canal whatever that may be you were you
have to do an anal that you know
whatever your Canal is it's going to be
it's gonna be up like that look it's
gonna be like regular if you're standing
up like this it's gonna be like that so
it's gonna be tighter
hmm he slips that weiner in It's Gonna
feel bigger tell me I'm wrong hmm tell
me I'm wrong that's why doggy feels
better
okay and you don't gotta look at him so
you're really
you don't got to you know so you're
really but doing a down dog this is a
downward dog like you're arching your
back yeah and going full now are you
allowed to do other things while you're
having doggy can you answer emails
Facebook before you know Tick Tock
because that's the new thing yeah
um but if it's good I'll just talk I
thought you're talking about my
biological clock sorry if it's good I'll
just kind of just you know just lay
there and enjoy it maybe throw in a
couple but I feel like here's something
you didn't wear a big thumb finger
because you know what you just like
totally crystallize something I've
always thought which is remember when
Kim Kardashian's sex tape came out and
when I had sex before I was like
just be as loud as possible and then I
saw her sex tape and she was like
and I was like that's what guys like I
never watched it I need to go watch it
see what's doing that like so tiny she
was like
we know she wasn't in a math place no
she knows she knew exactly how to whoa
it was like little tiny like a like a
desk lost kitten I ain't never seen that
I know I gotta go look at it now but
here's what I'll say this is fucked up
that I
I don't like to make any noise during
sex is that weird
Spectrum library or you have anything to
say are you concentrating on the nut I'm
because that's sometimes me like I don't
speak because I'm like do you have a
boyfriend yeah who do I know I'm from
who is he on the show oh yes okay well
this is tricky because we have a
fuckmary kill Libby Paige brat for you
Tammy happy birthday oh
kill
oh okay I would want to fuck
please see me
I only like wieners I need you to talk
through it okay if you're gonna fuck
Brett that's gonna fuck up your
relationship I don't think so but Paige
oh not if you kill her
all right right okay he's not through
this he's the only wiener and I only
like wiener but if I'm going if if
that's the route I gotta take It's gotta
be Brett sure but if I'm going with like
it doesn't matter my sexual orientation
you know what I mean yeah I I'd probably
fuck Paige how would that go just
scissor okay I don't I'm gonna say it
look I have masqueraded for the past 10
15 years to people as if I know a lot
about sex I don't know that much about
sex I don't know how scissoring would
happen
you just okay let's say you know like a
pair of scissors that you'd uh like cut
something with I I do you know how the
bottom moment kind of does that I do
yeah and listen I've never scissored
either but this is what I'm thinking you
seem defensive how well you know I I'm
just saying your legs would scissor like
that I'd spread them out so those are
Tammy's likes and then you'd come up
you'd have your scissors and then we
just kind of flop and then just kind of
go because you know your badge is right
there in your back but then they just
you're just rubbing Clips they just bump
up on each other yeah but how do you
know they're gonna match
if you don't go you don't know what do
you think come tastes like I think it
tastes kind of every guys come tastes
different see it all tastes the same to
me what you had such a different
reaction to the bacon you're known for
your taste buds oh Tammy oh Tammy oh
Tammy we trust you with your taste buds
but come has come
yeah but vegans are vegan there's
different textures I'll tell you that
yeah there's thin chunky and yellow
where's your preferred come spot
foreign
I like it up in there okay cream pies
yeah okay I just like to feel the throb
how dirty we wanting to get you want to
feel the heartbeat exactly this is the
under the episode we do not need to be
monetized don't need to be monetized all
right I got that new money I'm good then
don't pull out for nothing
for nothing okay nothing nothing get up
in there these guys want to see their
that's true come um have you ever had a
guy come in your back and lick it off I
haven't huh he looks I've never had a
man who licks his own cum off me he's
usually like like nuts and then he's
like oh Welcome to Hollywood baby that'd
be wild to see honestly I wouldn't be
mad I'd be like thanks for cleaning
that's a bummer where are we at ass
eating where'd we land on that
I don't eat ass neither do I well here's
the thing I won't eat a man's ass
if I was
dating women into women oh I I you know
she's got one of the best buttholes I've
ever seen look I'm being honest let me
ask you about that how do you
get a good butthole
she ain't never bleaching I don't know
nothing it's all natural I don't know
because it's just there and I you know I
don't I don't even scrub can you
describe a bad butthole I don't even
like get a loofah or anything I don't
why not I've got those mitts I do those
Korean spiders and I and I scrub up in
there between the crevices I'm sorry
isn't it filled with like bacteria they
say like not if you wash it no oh no
you've never washed your ass no
that's why it looks so good there's no
like a abrasives
extra what like my boyfriend has a clit
looking on his butthole that's a
deflated hemorrhoid it looks like bacon
huh
I'm not even kidding you he's got pussy
lips on his butthole no
dude it's it's the one of the wildest
Things I've ever seen in my life
oh we show each others have you never
been with a woman no never
I rubbed a clit once and started gagging
I swear to God and I was like from the
texture of the smell
texture or the cracks and the screaming
and then please stop and I was like I
can't man I can't but also you know your
pussy if you finger someone else you
don't know it's new every time this is
why I actually have compassion for men
because you get to know it you know how
to make a woman have an orgasm and then
you move on to another one it's like
back to one you're an open Micah again
wow that's a good I never thought about
that I never thought about that
mind-blowing yeah how would you know
what to do
you're right where would you what would
you have done after what so who was this
person and you just stopped and that was
fine
yeah we were in a strip club why do I
feel like her name is Shelly we were at
ecstasy in Dallas I was working at Whole
Foods at the time and the whole crew
went out
and we were just making out and I was
like you know what like right in the
middle of this is a huge of Whole Foods
no oh okay okay this is a big Club
there's probably a thousand people in
there I'm sorry this is party it's just
one of the to me it's one of the best
strip clubs and I've been to a lot and
um
we're making out and and uh I was like
let me uh let me see what this is about
what's she wearing just jeans okay did
you rub the clip of the jeans no I went
inside True Religion diesel miss me back
then I think it was uh was it zipper
butterfly buttons oh it was zipper or
maternity jeans the one with the plastic
low-rise zipper did you unzip it I can't
remember I think I just slipped my hand
in there
and I I was like get me fucking out of
there get me out of I literally started
gagging did you have uh the tips on did
it what were your nails no they looked
like this like that maybe and I said
um
yeah I like just like leaner strictly
which is weird because chicks are hot
but what if what these threesomes that
you're you're working on what if there's
a woman involved in the three-way
because I'm worried about your safety
your intestinal safety what if you want
a lady with a strap on she can lick my
pussy all day I'll do that okay I would
do that yep but when it comes to me
touching one
I can't I've tried it in the strip club
no that's too much for me don't ask just
a lot going on down there the texture
was real weird almost bubble gummy did
she have on underwear yeah
some bubble gum just stuck it down there
I know a girl let me tell you something
she's the hit of La when I moved here
every guy was obsessed with her and I
just straight up cornered her one night
at a club and I was like what's your why
is everyone obsessed with you and she
went I put Cherry chapstick on my pussy
whoa
so when guys eat around it tastes like
cherries tell me later who it was she
was almost the first female president of
this United States wow fucking up the
bell curve and I said to her you need to
stop that right now because you're
screwing it up for the rest of us but
wouldn't that be waxy
guys are guys yeah yeah they put Pomade
in their hair they don't understand
consistencies they're already licking a
pussy I mean that's just to them making
it taste better not only does it taste
like cherries but it's nostalgic it's
like oh it smells like Mommy also
they're leaving going that's actually
what that tastes like I don't know
they're going to the world being like
that's correct yeah oh she's just as
sweet as a cherry even though it's not
that's not what's supposed to smell like
wow smell like Wharf chicken livers uh
best and works worst sex positions okay
so doggy style is number one hands down
literally hands down ass up number two
best me on top
okay but we can go with the worst right
now but why why would you ever want to
be on top oh you don't like to be on top
I don't have time oh no that's my
favorite but I if you sit there and post
up and then he thrusts up that's fine
with me yeah yeah no I like it all
because I don't understand if I'm
supposed to be going this way or up and
down or a horse I do a little bit both I
do it all okay I do a little bit of a
rocking horse
I usually wait till they go
and then I'm like okay they like that
and then you're like wake up yeah and
then I'm like fucked did my legs are
good but are you touching the nipples
while you're doing it squeezing it no
how do you work where are we didn't
touch their nipples should be arrested
no no women like that you know I'm in
the fuck people and they're doing this
when they're fucking somebody you should
be uh uh
well I'd be not get out of here they
want you to do it what if they want you
to do it you're a doggy style how are
you gonna they're just doing it by their
self they're alone no no you're you're
touching that okay so you're not if your
doggy style they're alone back there
that's not what I'm talking about when
you're on top when you're on top and the
guys on the bottom you got to grab onto
something to hold on to so you're gonna
put it out of the nipples foreign
I've never seen a man rub his nipples oh
there's guys that are in a nipple really
yep yep yep I had a guy however I had a
guy bite my nipples so hard they started
bleeding and couldn't wear a shirt for
three days yeah what yeah he was an
otter no he was the brother of uh pop
star that rhymes with Babin
Papa
let's see he was the brother I thought
it was him and I oh God I hooked up with
the wrong I hook up with the celebrities
brother brother Melba's fixed but I did
also make out with Adam Durrett so I
have I have put my time in whoa yeah
let's see worst worst sex position I'm
gonna vote while you think up against
tomorrow yeah I'm gonna vote I'm gonna
throw it up against a wall and also this
thing where they try to grab you in like
a reverse piggyback like you not you
don't take enough creatine yeah you're
not Brandon chop you can't you can't
sustain this you thought you were gonna
sustain this you can need more CC I'm
gonna say you over you're about two
worst okay
like laying up or setting up on like a
table or something and having them come
up
no I'm not doing that oh when you're on
a table a table a desk something like
that but here's the question if he's
your car if his dick is your same height
as your vagina it can be great but if
you have to put your
um uh Caboose took us off the table and
hold it right because he's too short
that's gonna be a sciatica well and if
but even if it is the same height and
there's no wall behind you and you got
to hold yourself up not today not today
not this week okay not at all no no only
Tammy we don't do this if we're gonna do
this it's gonna be monetized let's do it
regularly yeah this isn't for free right
um and then I'm gonna say it I mean I'm
gonna ruffle some feathers here oh I'm
Really Gonna ruffle some feathers here
reverse cowgirl oh wow get out right now
the winner always pops out and slips out
always always and then you go down on it
and you worry you broke it always that's
the worst worst and you got to pretend
it didn't happen it's uncomfortable uh
he's looking at my butthole no yeah by
the way which by the way we got to talk
about we have different buttholes I I
did the anal bleaching thing and then
early 2000s before they'd figured it out
and what happened I don't know it could
look like a dairy cow back there it
sploshed it did not distribute evenly I
went to Vegas once and the first time I
ever like people started like knowing me
or damning me they're like we'll do free
asshole that was my first um paid
partnership was will come and bleach
your asshole and I went and it was not a
legitimate um operation I don't think it
was at a woman's apartment and she just
had a thing of bleach yeah and it was
like it was like no it was a gel that
she put on and then she went next to
fabuloso and then it was sun in and then
she put a hairbrush oh no I'm sorry a
she had to brush my hand hair no she put
a hair dryer over it to let it like bake
in and then she was like you have to use
this four times a day for the next two
years
like this smells like a lot of homework
yeah and then she gave her a pack of
Crestline strips in her home and she
goes using the next three months
she had a dark ass
too gone
wow that was way easier than that but I
did I have lasered my asshole you've not
done that if you've got a full job
you'll see her butthole and you'll be
impressed why don't we try another dog
and then I'm gonna say what does your
bicycle seat smell like is a big
question I got that question from a
couple different people
can we try a corn dog yes we can would
you like to try a sauce honey I'll try
and they are hot hold on but this is you
want to read it baby
hold on but it's the what what it is is
on here it's 98 Peppers oh god oh no
it's just gonna fuck up the whole day
they're really hot I told you that oh
and that one's 86 oh well when it comes
to that grenade form you know something
cayenne peppers distilled white vinegar
salt garlic oh God so just a couple
simple ingredients okay show us how to
do it how to dip it okay I'm gonna
hold on hold on honey I'm gonna have a
little dip to it it's thick okay is it
you got a big you got a big little dip
there these are things I've never seen
such a thick dog all right y'all ready
okay so this is the hottest possible
we're doing fuck you hot ones we're
doing our own hot ones we don't need you
here we go ready okay honey
it's a hot dog
I can smell it it's on my lips
my ones on my face
oh uh oh her brow is furrowed uh oh the
queen of the mukbangs is not happy or
she's close to me you never know with
her you can go either way the second MMA
fight you never know how it's gonna go
with her you never know
you could think she hates it and she
loves it you can think she loves it and
she hates it this is it this is the
Zagat review
face is red
you're good
how are you doing not bad
okay
okay that was a journey that was a
journey that was a Oh the hot sauce hit
me now bam okay but you know I think
that the um they're trying to fucking
kill us
we had that you had that deep that's a
very simple dog I taste the corn which I
like I really taste the corn do you want
taste it it's corn it's very good the
meat it's corn driven it's very
flavorful lots of flavors in the meats
yeah
okay lots of flavors yep
onion powder uh-huh I think it's just
onions
garlic okay
corn loss of salt corn uh-huh it's corn
forward it's pretty good but don't keep
eating because there's more to go okay
there's more to go we got you got a
little a couple bites of each thing all
right
um and then we gotta get because you
still have an answer fuck Mary kill um
Libby page bro
because she's amazing the best kill
Brett easily
easy how would you do it the first thing
that came to my mind was like Drano some
sort of drinking Drano how much Drano
kill someone no friend oh something like
that inserting him with poison of some
sort please this is important if you
were gonna kill someone how would you do
it a little bar keeps friend in a shot
glass which is what Cleaning Supply I
don't understand anything that's
happening okay so now when I kill
someone yeah what is all everything you
just said I would kill someone like
I would invite them on a trip obviously
this is an expensive murder I would
invite them on a trip no no like a
picnic I would invite them on a trip
we'd have a picnic like how you recently
invited me out I find out they're
allergies I'd be like and then I would
like I would put like peanuts maybe in
something okay get some fire ants a wasp
a yellow jacket guess what did you get
they'd have a yeppy pin no they wouldn't
because I earlier see earlier in the day
I'd be like just a dart and I'd throw it
toss it okay what is this EpiPen thing
oh yeah you gotta think about that and
then you D also what if they if they had
an EpiPen it's just me and them maybe I
don't understand you need what what do
you need that's good like that yeah
that's good an episode of what so you're
gonna you want to watch the person die
that you kill in front of you you found
a killer in the situation yeah picnic
blanket usually that's why people do it
you want to go to the grocery store
before you kill someone
oh no it would be empty no but all the
food that you're jamming peanuts into
how do you know that it's a
life-threatening allergy oh I'd ask
and then I wouldn't I wouldn't put
peanuts I put because on my hand and I'd
be like good morning that's such a
specific thing poison how would you kill
someone
[Music]
um
you know you've never thought about this
before that's weird I think I'd just get
it done quick you know like a little
little gun shot to the do you have a gun
gotta be untraceable gotta be untrusted
I'll get one though the real move though
is to do a saw situation I say w and do
it nobody no problem you know yeah get
people in somewhere and they can go
through some games yeah I think you know
you got to take out the toenails and the
teeth you got to hammer them out give
them a paper cut to a ball sack may make
them bleed and bleed toes what's the
word when you when you drain someone's
blood you um drain in blood you could um
no there's a word for it drinking blood
and then we're gonna you're gonna know
and then Tammy's gonna teach us people
and tie them over bamboo and then bamboo
only grows straight up so it'll go right
through you
that's torture and death whoa it goes
straight into yeah
do you guys know I've licked her asshole
was this on only Tammy no this is
something okay this is something that we
can see this is just for fun this is it
was just for fun it was not a lot of the
game my guy's asshole
he climbs rocks like he's a rock
climbing person so it's full of Pebbles
and his butt is like very big like hard
and big and if you try to touch his
butthole which I have not tried many
times
um yeah I'm not interested but I'm glad
to have I'm glad that once I was like I
have to try this I'm 30 whatever uh he's
a veterinarian I gotta keep him
um it was like you know the end of a
sausage where it's tied with a little
piece of metal it's like that like the
linguista yeah how was the taste I know
that was just my finger and then I was
like okay great so are you back there
fingering it no no no no he's on top of
each other yeah no there's no I'm never
on I am never first of all not just
lying there but I don't get up and I'm
making a special trip you're laying
there
you're just laying there reaching them
about that that's bigger big big what
finger do you go in with middle always
middle because of fuck you it's just the
most it's the longest and it's the
furthest away from my palm yeah
it's the furthest away from my mouth
yeah
what I'm saying it's nice to go what are
you supposed to do a finger in the butt
with I don't really do much the point
if you want to get a butt plug you can
do whatever you want but I'm not getting
involved yeah I get hangnails hey
usually I would pay okay so you explain
this to me so a friend of mine a guy
friend of mine recently got pegged by
his girlfriend didn't go great and she
has a Blog so if you're gonna Peg don't
do it with a girl with a Blog but so
they're not together no they're not so
you are putting on a mm-hmm
strap it on right with a is it oh like
underwear is it like a fanny pack
but it goes around your butt too to hold
it it looks like a jock strap yeah jock
strap yeah I don't think I could ever do
that
and laugh I would love to but do you
think you'd be able to thrust at the
pace necessary yeah I can't why oh I
could what music do you need to put
something good and good and hard like
maybe corn Freebird
put that Limp Biscuit on just one of
those days yeah when you don't want to
wink I would literally love that just I
could be good at that okay sure and then
how do you know when you're done pegging
you got me there they come how do you
know it's over you got me okay but then
they just say I came through my G-spot
on my butt and then it's over
just like the regular come guys can just
come like that I don't know yeah if you
go to the prostate doctor they can just
poke it and you'll come yeah I think
that happened to my boyfriend I stuck my
finger up there and I think I milked
them yeah like what happened he came out
of his dick not his butthole yeah it was
like almost a powder and then he wasn't
it was in powder almost okay we need to
hydrate we need some power yeah but then
he was like I'm not done coming and then
like oh his wee-wee was still hard and
then oh
screams the butthole orgasm is a whole
thing we looked it up and I milked his
prostate
well it wasn't quite powder but are you
a big blowjob lady
me uh you know it's not it's probably my
favorite thing to do I give a blowjob a
couple days ago but you know how'd it go
10 seconds done what that's not true do
it what okay so just do my eye we have
brought a couple items for y'all to
watch Mr we have a sex toy mukbang as
well let's see what we got here we've
got a banana so you can show us all how
to get blow jobs oh that's we're going
to show you how we give
laughs
okay okay that's free we want to be
clear if someone was born like that hold
on that one I've got an app for oh
that's you can control that that's what
all the that's what all the ChatterBait
people do where does it go what's
ChatterBait that's where it's like
chatting but masturbating hey Grace what
is that thing you put it in your butt
and then someone else can control it
I've got an app to control it but I
can't find the app is it the right there
is it the New York Times app how do you
get this in your ass no that's that's
the fatty you have to pull it out is it
because you can't have something in your
ass that doesn't have a base
I feel like Reddit would control that
what I don't remember that I forgot the
name of it you hold that one second you
put those between your legs and you'll
your life's about to change your most
recently downloaded apps that is a
grenade that clit Tickler okay is that
so walk me through that it's on because
I have a question that was asked by your
fans numerous times
Clint Tickler yes or yes
explain to me yeah why
a Clint Tickler is probably probably my
favorite thing in the world okay
um is that the right size no I would not
pick that why not too big my clip's not
that big yeah that's wild my clits maybe
you know the side
what's happening what's happening
controlling this oh what's happening
mode six are you not okay someone just
okay great that's two I mean I'm thrown
I'd be able to note with this but I'd
like to just a little just alone
yeah okay that's my favorite thing to do
okay I'm gonna give this to you put that
on I'm gonna give Paige the uh app of
this so explain to me what I'm looking
at because I thought these were kegel
balls it kind of looks like a Benoit
ball kind of looks like a Toy Story what
would that be considered like a eight
it's a plug and then this is to pull it
out
it kind of does like the infinity sign
with a with a string okay it looks like
those lip balms that are in circle balls
um yeah oh yeah uh ethos
it's made for you to wear all day
can you turn it off is this going your
asshole and your uh just your asshole I
think crevice balls because this one
goes in the second hole and then goes in
the first hole but my taint is not this
small is that off your asshole holes
there's two asshole holes whoa
you scared me me too
me too oh my God okay I put it on my
vagina just to kind of put them as a
Pikachu as a placeholder I didn't think
you were gonna go Rogue over there I
didn't know it said mode six okay mode
six is a that's a that's a high mode
that's a high mode I'm gonna put this
between my legs like just my thighs kind
of feels good so the idea is that you
and your person like your lover get okay
that's I know a lot of only fans people
will let their fans control the app see
I would never do that I have an orgasm
with that I it makes me upset it makes
me feel like I'm getting a UTI yeast
infection combo because of the why
foreign
this is a let's just describe it for the
audio viewers it is a pastel pink uh
pointer wiener with a little crab leg on
the back I think it's called like a
rabbit ear a little looks like little it
looks like a snail but does that go in
the butthole no that goes in your
clothes this goes in your pussy can I
tell you something crazy I've never used
a sex toy on my own me either I swear to
God I know
sex story my favorite sex toy man
no there's something better out there
but I've never used
I've had guys
to them like just kind of whatever
um because they were whatever it
couldn't get hard anymore or something
oh no I dated older guys for a while I'm
all about masturbating really with what
I I love it's called the satisfier pro
and it sucks on your clip
and I will bust a nut in 10 seconds
start to finish just knock it out at
Howard Johnson I can go from non-horny
to Bustin no in 10 seconds flat and does
the hubs is threatened by this no he
can't keep up with my sex drive he can't
keep up with the sucker 5000. no not at
all would you agree that most guys
the the ass seating it feels like that
is it is what it is I'm never gonna be
able to figure that out but
going down on a girl how often are you
like
I couldn't do better than that
see it's weird because I feel like maybe
I could just because I know what I know
what to do they don't know oh
unless you guys you know you got to tell
them without yelling or reminding them
with their mom you just go oh that feels
good yeah and then keep doing that yeah
exactly I do that okay you know so yep
it's all post-verbal exactly me
oh yeah something like that oh yeah did
you ever do that oh hell yeah oh all the
time before you suck a dick do you like
tap on it
only on camera that yeah I mean I I'm
gonna be honest we didn't know I'm
usually don't do that with food but now
you got me thinking about it I'll
probably try it just to see you know so
walk me through this is a grenade that
is a this is a clit Tickler I don't
understand why it's so big
eyes balls you could you can do anything
you want it feels too aggressive you do
whatever you want it feels it feels too
aggressive what do you have over there
Tammy this is the Big Clip clip thing
and all you gotta do is lay back stick
it on there you don't take that inside
that's a whole grenade I bet people do I
would not because I bust clit wise not
insertion wise can I there's two kind of
orgasms people don't talk about that
you're the mountain not the cave there
is and I've that I've rarely inside is
very hard to make happen it's very rare
has it happened so dark maybe I have
only had that happen sitting on a chair
chair in a chair in an acting class
no it was just like it was just if if
you if I sit on top of a gent uh and
like lean forward and Tracy Anderson
myself within a nightmare and get a
sciatica I can do it but I just I ca
it's not worth it to me yeah
I've only vaginally came a few times I'm
gonna be honest with you what was the
doggy style
um uh me on top okay I feel like most of
the time but it's did you leave with a
uh torn hammy
um no hmm no no
I've got strong legs could walk fine the
next day yeah yeah and I've only
squirted while being on top as well okay
so talk me to me about squirting is that
squirting or is it more like run down
I've came vaginally without squirting
I'm gonna be honest with y'all when I
came in here I said I was a squirter
I've only squirted a couple times and
what happened that's counts it only
takes one okay okay technically you're
right to be a squirter uh first time I
squirted was not too long ago okay maybe
two years ago yeah and I got when I was
watching um Dateline and I got horny
what was the story I wasn't paying
attention I just thinking was that the
one you know what the one that got me
was when um Tiger Woods uh drove into a
sign and broke his legs oh that's a good
one yeah everything the Casey Anthony
trial
I have killed all of them
I got warning
um Daryl was in there in bed and I said
I'm going there and wake his ass up you
know and uh I went in there climbed on
top didn't no no oral or nothing okay no
last time no oral okay matter of fact I
wasn't even ready
um my vag wasn't ready if you know what
I'm saying so I had to get ready myself
wasn't dripping you know what I'm
talking about I think there's something
hot about it not being all flooded right
away yeah agree don't you think and I
climbed on top but so do you just handle
that you'll just be like you'll lick
your hand and just handle it okay and I
had a real quick I had a debate about
this on Instagram where people were
saying that it's nasty to use your own
spit and you're getting kicked off of
Instagram this is shocking
yeah you got me but I was like what
what's what's so now like you don't use
spit
I mean at that point you're already
there I mean you're already inside of
somebody what does it matter spin is not
lube and what else is not Lube blood
lick it and stick it so anyway I climbed
on top and I was riding maybe 20 seconds
and I squirted for the first time and it
was unbelievable did you think you were
peeing no it was completely different
because women are very confused about
this is it pink color was that I did it
was dark and I didn't see but it was
clear okay when I got up nope trying my
Lots but the the but the orgasm was not
like a clit orgasm it was completely
different oh I went and woke up my
sisters and told them okay I put it on
Snapchat I was like I just squirted for
the first time you know I wondered if I
didn't know um did you get good
oh yeah um money no well everybody was
happy for me okay you know how old were
you when this happened two years two
years ago because you also have to like
psychologically let go for that to
happen yes you have to be like I'm
paying I'm being I'm being I'm peeing
but let it just don't giggle is that
your goal now
what is your goal now to squirt every
time or are you just like it's fine I'm
gonna be honest with y'all I don't think
I'll ever be able to do to do it again
uh-huh we're gonna hydrate you we've
hydrated you to the point of I think
it's gonna happen tonight how do those
big tits fart
foreign
well I can't make mine fart okay
um so or I mean but I can get them
slapping is that what you mean I don't
even know if y'all can see this but I
got I gotta you know a side tip a side
Tech yeah side boom very end right now
I'm very in right now show them thank
you show them
okay yeah by the way uh one of the eight
Wonders of the World I added a wonder
that is a Wonder one of the best sites
thank you excellent thank you excellent
work
um I just shot my new calendar
oh Tammy calendar I got one picture back
here that might get us demonetized but
that ship has sailed All I'm gonna say
is if you think you were nutting last
year
you ain't seen nothing yet yeah
I show ass in this one so how do you
know I feel like every woman
has like a
secret very embarrassing if they were to
talk about in public angle they know
they look cute at how do you choose your
positions in the in the calendar how do
you know well
foreign
I'm gonna be honest with you and I'm not
trying to sound conceited here but I
really look good at all of them that's
true that is it's hard for me to pick
between the pictures we take because
they're all good honestly it's an
embarrassment of riches it's all good I
just know like if I'm lying down I'll
put my arms kind of under my boobs so
that they go up because well I've got
faces because it reminds her when she
had to wear that straight jacket
so I'll hold it up it's just so that my
boobs look so perfect tits yes yes did
it hurt
which part of the terms of fact you need
them that Bell when I didn't like it I'm
thrilled I look good thank you agree
yeah I've had a cup I've had to do it a
couple times and um just for fun though
my boobs were different sizes not all of
us are blessed like this this uh Tammy
but um yeah I love them and they're kind
of not super obvious to everybody else
because they're very wide yeah I never
see them I'm wearing the worst bra ever
I decided to wear a strapless bra for
you guys I don't know what got into me
how crazy no they look good how did the
farts happen oh I don't titty fart are
you talking about just something like
this maybe someone just really
we hold that up right there
is that what you mean
that's what I meant yeah and they are
sweaty right now I do not know how to
make that noise with my body yeah I
could never do that if you're listening
those are my titties
slapping together that was not um a fly
swatter no against the wall
hands you throw back and forth they clap
it's the weirdest request you have
gotten in terms of a cameo a DM a photo
Emily was asked actually uh within two
months of uh coming back and working
here and being on camera to fart in
underwear was that it oh what was it no
well oh to give yourself a wedgie Sorry
God no no for 7 500 and she didn't take
it I got a cameo one time to make fun of
myself my boyfriend's dick but I didn't
do it yeah that's a smart pass I get a
lot of people wanting to buy my dirty
underwear okay but how dirty what is
dirty underwear mean
excess semen that's been coming out
what's all day all day let's just say I
think they want it so dirty that you
could put fish oil on it and they
wouldn't know the difference cod liver
oil
krill oil yeah yeah you want to smell
like a quarry yeah okay that's what they
like
are these prison inmates are these
people that are just I think it's just
Grandpa's yeah okay
trying to understand if they're roaming
about oh yeah is there a particular city
or state where you get the most most
frequent requests for this is there like
have you narrowed it down to a certain
type of person father of twins they're
spread out Browns fans okay now do you
have fetishes I love Grandpa's good
looking Grandpa yeah
they appreciate us they get older that's
probably my thing anything else really
what's the perfect age
well I'm getting older now so what it
used to be is not the same you know okay
why is it the guys like go younger and
we go older
well we match their uh you know the
frontal lobe yeah that's true at a
younger look at you yeah I shed my head
and I know about the frontal lobe yeah
riddle wrapped in a rhyme yeah shit on
my frontal lobe that's what you got to
do you got to shit on your head your
favorite sex toy Tammy
satisfier Pro that's right you said that
can we find that on adamandeve.com you
can do you still squirt in quartz
you have fans I've done that one time
okay I have squirt I've squirted average
size Squirts and one time I did squirt a
quart size it doesn't matter how much
you've hydrated before what's the
pre-squirting plan three hours ahead of
time I don't ever plan nothing nothing
I've never planned I've never drank
extra
okay how do you prefer a guy hit on you
be straightforward hey
you're hot as fuck are you like a dick
or no dick pigs oh is this in person on
the internet oh just let's fuck
in person
mode do we want vanish mode uh I ain't
worried I ain't scared about nothing you
can keep me off famous mode okay
um but no just hey let's fuck none of
that whole hey what are you doing I
don't want to hear that you know I don't
talk or not and I only do it I just want
to be straight with you guys I'll really
only fuck other men if Daryl's in jail
honestly I that that is that takes a lot
of Integrity you know what I mean I'm
proud of you right well it started okay
if if you listen you don't know what I'm
talking about my husband Daryl we've
been together a long time and um you
know he's in jail often and so he's
getting plenty of sex oh he's scared
that was part of the thing yeah he was
getting arrested all this time for just
little things you know in there and I
got tired of it I said I'm tired of him
going to jail and I still got needs
who's gonna take care of my needs uh-huh
Cheryl Sandberg
so finally I just said Daryl next time
you go to jail I'm sorry I'm sorry baby
but I've gotta go flourish and do my
thing you know I got I right you gotta
do that rum Springer thinking that he'd
go no baby don't do that and stay out of
jail with motherfucker got arrested a
week later
four
petty theft I'm just gonna say that okay
so let's stealing Hospital you know so
he knows he knows I said you're in there
getting blow jobs
yeah that's fine I don't care drop the
soap yeah yeah jobs it's not great for
him well so am I you know what I mean
and he knows it so we're we have an
agreement that if he's in jail I'm free
do whatever I want so it's an open
relationship as long as you don't or
unless you it's an open relationship if
you break the law yeah but once he's out
monogamy true okay well I don't need
nothing else sure you know yeah
um but I'll hop on Tinder my Instagram
DMs I mean everybody all my followers
want to fuck me okay they really do and
how much would it cost for them
to make that dream a reality
well I don't charge for nothing that's
against the law
that's right
no I don't I'm not a you know I don't
really don't do that yeah you're not
you're not greedy like you're like dates
I make enough money you know what I mean
first date perfect first date let's say
Daryl's in jail for a year and you're
like you know what I'm looking for a
number two that's consistent I want a
gentleman side piece Cracker Barrel by
the interstate well if he's got Cracker
Barrel money
damn I don't even want to know no I've
been a Cracker Barrel once in my life
really yeah did you love it I love
Cracker Barrel they got all the candies
and stuff you can buy before you go in
it's I've never seen them clothes you
can buy clothes for church right there
this is one of your birthday gifts
hahaha
it's a Cracker Barrel hat you crack her
Barrel oh Cracker Barrel cracked her man
get in there oh okay okay now we're all
horny now your DMs are just gonna be a
fucking mess
um thank you for this this is amazing
um
uh something not you know what I I dress
up real nice looking for a pair of jeans
okay
jeggings or full jeans with buttons oh
no I'll do the full full Wrangler
Wrangler Zips zippers no buns take me
somewhere nice you know it you know I
want to be really wand and done if we're
talking about a relationship here
somewhere nice maybe chili's Spinners
yeah
um and then about pants like a like a
county fair or a NASCAR race or oh now
now I'll fall in love with a NASCAR race
I will
um but let's don't beat around the bush
let's fuck in the parking lot okay
before in the car
hood of the car where I don't give what
kind of car what's the hottest car to
fuck on
um I like the older I like the older PT
Cruiser well
I wouldn't do that
the PT Cruiser men no no they don't have
that Cracker no no they get their
Propecia from Canada let's don't do that
no
um that's a hard pass you know I I like
I like a truck
um so now I'm sometimes a minivan sure
you know a Daewoo there's just because
there's space in there
so we gotta take the seats out we'll put
them down at least you can sprawl out in
a minivan sure
look and what does Daryl how does he
feel about your open relationship that's
only open on your side he don't want to
know nothing okay so he says he said
he'd just say baby I don't want to know
nothing you don't tell me nothing on bro
don't tell him shit okay you know Fair
it's easier it's easier that way um he
ain't got no nothing I ain't got saying
that I don't got a skin top no that's my
that's my business that's your business
that's my business
yeah I believe you that ain't his
business
anyway he opened it up so you opened it
up exactly now it's time for us to
audition
uh sucking dicks okay for you
okay and one of us will get an
appearance on only Tammy okay
I'm the judge oh are we ready all right
this is good for you is God Talent ready
go
wait what are you doing oh why are you
why is she doing that the beginning is
this okay you got the deck first you got
to do suck the top first get it wet get
it
let's just you want to do everything
under it and then up huh because you're
going that's too fast you're trying to
be done already no no no yes you are not
at first because that's where the most
nerve endings are right here yeah you
got that right now uh-huh oh oh no oh no
oh wow no oh wow
oh
clean absolutely not I mean to each
their own I guess Christ just fit and
then you're done I just spit on the
banana you're hard thank you thank you
ma'am that was better than I thought it
was gonna be okay
okay I'm impressed thank you I thought
she was gonna Deep Throat the banana and
swallow it no you gotta get spit and
then yeah you did everything you're
supposed to do thank you I think the
gagging helps the spit coagulate mm-hmm
okay yep yep yep I I well it got you
spit up
spit and then it's handled that's what
happens you when you have you have to
know how to do that if you have a dry
pussy yeah ooh mine's mine's wet right
now okay mine too yeah yeah yeah Queen
of England yeah
hello my adoring subjects and listeners
of the good for you podcast
I interrupt this interview because I'm
horrified by the content and think given
the improper subject matter of this
program I'd like to offer you
my most Royal and divine advice
no no this is an ad for our sponsor
betterhelp you're talking about the
wonderful professional advice they can
give our listeners my dear who could
give better advice to your people than
me a queen of the people now hush as I
answer these questions yes ma'am hey
good for you team no I think she's
meaning hello dearest members of the
good for your kingdom but I digress I am
having a really hard time finding ways
to stay positive as I move towards my
dreams and goals any advice on how not
to compare
ooh compare and despair
yeah well
here we go my dear sweet sad subject
is very simple you walk down the
corridors of your Castle right into the
Vault where you keep your mini crown
jewels pick up your crown place it upon
your divinely chosen head and keep a
staff you know a stiff upper lip and
remember it's not about you and how
you're feeling it's about what is best
for your monarchy that you are chosen to
rule
it's only ever about the crown and also
dear maybe take some time to pop that
puss with the girlies
blast some rap and get wasted
huh that was advice I guess but your
majesty I'm not sure it's relatable and
it has nothing to do with our sponsor
better help which is a wonderful and
convenient way to get help from a
licensed professional therapist it's not
a crisis line crisis what do you knew
about crisis one of my grandchildren is
a redhead at least the other one had the
decency to go bald
that does sound hard
you can start communicating in under 48
hours and best of all better help is
there to help you start living your best
life today can you say any more of that
maybe are you even listening of course
not yeah okay
better help that's better h-e-l-p better
help will assess your needs and match
you with your own licensed professional
therapist it's not a crisis line it's
not self-help it's professional
counseling done securely online and
based on the fact that I am wearing a
horse Tiara I don't need it at all there
is a broad range of expertise available
which may not be locally available in
many areas the services available for
clients worldwide you can log into your
account anytime and send a message to
your counselor you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone session
and best of all we have a deal for you
good for you listeners uh to help you
get started today betterhelp.com Whitney
that's better help.com and join the over
a million people who have taken charge
of their mental health with the help of
an experienced professional this podcast
is sponsored by betterhelp what a
coincidence and good for you listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
Whitney are you a little jealous that my
crown is bigger than yours yes it is I
know I don't have to do something about
that it's a power move you could execute
Peter anybody outstages the queen
sorry Benton why won't you stop looking
at my butt because it's always in the
way
of what everything you're you're
sweeping hallways at this point
as you walk it's just it's too much it's
called switching
my butt's switching that's what's called
switch switch why is it like that what
are you doing
sounds like you're jealous it sounds
like
um
I did not go to Brazil and get a
Brazilian butt lift I did not do that uh
not because I didn't want to just
because if Grace didn't book The Ticket
I couldn't have gotten there so she will
testify that I didn't my butt has gotten
so
juicy look at that hold on hold on look
at that juicy butt
see that
wild my butt's wild it is um it is it's
changed yeah and the big secret you
ready no I'm not getting random liquid
concrete from Russia and pouring it in
there no I'm not doing injections not
that I'm against it but I am using fast
food it's I do uh kind of I don't need
that much collard greens who collard
greens I'm eating literally whatever I
want at this point because I have the
hydro y'all have seen me talk about it
you see me on it you've seen me uh how
my body has transformed since I have had
it in my life it is it literally Works
86 percent of your muscles as compared
to other workouts like cycling like when
I was doing just cycling I did not gain
any muscles in my arms or my back or my
abs like nothing so cycling only works
44 of your body not Hydro the hydro
rowing machine
86 like the only muscles that doesn't
work are what like your facial muscles
basically
I started using hydro everybody is
asking me about my body I am not using a
trainer and we thought that was over I
used to get I used to go to like a
personal trainer all the time and my
body still was not like this okay and I
am it is not often that I will give
myself a compliment but I'm going to say
it my body is a slamming did slamming
I'm glad though because I feel like you
being my rowing trainer was a little
touch and go there I don't think so I
think that was a full mind-body workout
and you're giving up a lot I'm I think I
think upgrading to a hydro is a good
idea I don't think this was healthy for
our relationship I mean I well done
people because I've always wanted a row
but before I had the hydro Benton would
coach me and it was and what builds more
muscle than fear
it wasn't a good look get back in your
box okay I'm trying okay that's okay but
I need to feel like I've competing okay
get to other people bro
bro
they're gonna get you but I need you I
need to like the other rowing people
that are also rowing with me that I that
make me work harder oh okay
[Music]
I'll clean you I need to I need that's
good I need to feel like you're beating
me and I am because that inspires me oh
wow this is so see how fast I'm swimming
that's good good healthy competition
all right well there's got to be a
better way
what's this what's this no I don't think
come on okay I don't earn your water
wings I don't think that's right okay
you're not even trying It's gotta be a
better way the state of the promise
no I'm not inspired I'm not inspired
okay okay
I don't think you're trying hard enough
look you're not getting your padlocks
why am I going Downstream why are you
seeing yourself bro there so you've
given up on me I feel like that is is
that emotional abuse verbal abuse or
physical abuse I'm not sure which one uh
oh that's a boot camp all of the above
that's a boot camp okay well it was
obviously very dangerous I probably got
tetanus that is not an ideal way very
dangerous kids play in the backyard
I'm here what are you talking about the
Hydro has solved all of my problems I am
just psyched that I do not have to uh
you know put myself in danger anymore in
order to get a full body workout one
membership with Hydro comes with
unlimited profiles for your whole family
you'll all have access to live and
on-demand workouts that include rowing
Pilates yoga strength conditioning and
more because I need to feel like I'm
competing against other people so
inspire me but it's like this yeah I'm
telling you if you can get me off of it
godspeed you guys can share it with me
but you're gonna have to like knock me
off in my glutes
but so you'll see other people that are
doing the same row with you at the same
time and you like compete with them and
like you'll see what number you are in
the order and then if you're like 50
you're like I gotta get to 52 and then
my Virgo takes over and then so if you
were 50 you'd want to get to 52
[Applause]
I do love it can I tell you we were
doing the row that was Boston the other
day my friend Nick who's from Boston he
was like pointing out he's like oh
that's where I went to school and that's
where like you know I used to like went
to prom and like all this stuff so make
Hydro tour guide it is it is really like
a kind of like a tour of of a city in
addition to getting that switch and
tushy and right now Hydro is offering
200 off a hydro rower at hydro.com this
promo code won't last and is only valid
through November go to hydro.com right
now use the promo code Whitney that's
Hydro
h-y-d-r-o-w.com promo code Whitney also
I sent one to Gabby Reese and Laird
Hamilton who are the two most just like
athletic
um
Marvels and they posted about it and
it's their new favorite machine so if
you don't look to me for like body and
muscle advice look to me they co-sign
where do you stand on Lubes I don't ever
I mean I don't even have Lubes because I
really don't need them oh sorry for you
I know we we are going to do a quick
lube mukbang okay but maybe I you don't
need Lube though well I just don't
because I've there's already something
there you can just think about your
calendar well it's it's not a need it's
just a want okay okay so we have some
flavored Lubes okay and I just figured
since you're the queen of the mukbang
and you're the queen of the wet pussy
frankly why don't we take some of these
Loops banana lick oh sorry does it make
you a little numb huh juicy pineapple
this is a hold on this is a strawberry
kisses personal lubricant it's water
based because we like to stay hydrated
here this is a strawberry what do you
have I got I have an apple um juicy
pineapple I'm gonna put some on my
finger here I'm gonna put mine on this
banana it's Apple oh wow that's smart
you rubbed it all oh you're about to
okay okay Benson he just put the you put
the Lube on the banana and ate it I feel
like that's gonna make it taste better
than it deserves to taste no it's
actually really good oh
yeah this one's really good no that
tastes like tide with bleach
I'm not having a good time the pineapple
one's good
is it supposed to make your mouth numb
tropical passion is not good okay
strawberry is not good that's not that's
great that does not taste like a
strawberry
that yeah that one's nasty that tastes
like Summer's Eve I get pineapple's good
oh God that one's horrible mine tastes
like a Werther's original yours tastes
like medicine I don't think this is let
me taste it okay no matter what you do
Lube gets everywhere maybe it needs to
be on my glitter hold on for slides okay
what if we put it on a dick sorry
let's see there we go Tammy what do you
think of this this is strawberry kisses
[Music]
[Applause]
do you like the strawberry or do you
want the uh what's the other one mint
Chutney mint what else that's good hold
on I think okay
oh no Jesus this is the queen so this is
what we came here for uh Happy Birthday
uh Tammy 100th episode we are watching
Tammy uh take a cock in her mouth with
some strawberry uh chemicals on it and
I've never seen anything like this this
is uh if I were judging unreal
that's good put your name on it give it
a slap ooh
um
that's good are you okay Paige yeah
again if you need help just wink that
was good can we get the Lunchables
how the hell
once last time you all had Lunchables
those are expensive I wanted to revisit
for the 100th episode a couple things
tried to hide nachos so what do you want
it's your birthday Tammy Pizza here's
what I'm worried about I love Lunchables
when I was a kid I'm weird as an adult
or not that good oh I just stayed good
are you sure I never liked the pizza I
always liked the regular old lunchable
cracker cheese a little salami this is
making me nervous because I feel like
they're trying to get all fancy now one
is chicken nuggets and that makes me
real nice yeah do they need to be
microwaved no they're like Lunchables
makes a gazpacho now I'm like let's just
get back to the cheese I never got these
as a kid what
if you need to save that for your
ringtone you go right ahead I just
tapped on my lunchable if you're
listening and I'm gonna do it up close
ready
okay
and here it is what I got the Lunchable
extra cheesy pizza
comes with pizza crust pizza sauce craft
blend cheeses craft craft with a K
that's one yeah the Kardashians on it
having
hold on hold on Tammy face
there's a certain anger towards it like
I bet I Dare You Lunchables you got it
to make me squirt you got it I dare you
but does this need to be microwaves we
have to go microwave your little pizza I
don't think so are you sure kids don't
have microwaves in school you had them
in school yeah that looks like the skin
of an albino all right mod comes with a
little salsa uh little packet of sauce
here you need scissors
no it's got a little open they're for
kids
okay it also comes with the little pizza
crust
tap it
thank you okay here we go
I like extra sauce on mine okay they got
smaller nope no we got bigger oh that's
good okay
um
okay you sure
is it cold do we need it okay
what's your favorite pizza kind of pizza
you know what how do you feel about
pineapple I like pineapple great me too
me too I don't ever order it but if it's
there I'll eat it and enjoy it all right
you want me to dig in okay but that's
are you sure this isn't supposed to be
microwaved are you sure you're not
getting like scurvy or E coli are you
sure covet is not in that okay I'm not
sure about nothing okay but is that
supposed to be microwave I don't think
so
um
these are the Nuggets baby
oh yeah I'm gonna skimp out okay make
sure this mozzarella pasteurized
prepared cheese pizza sauce
okay
you're the boss
good but it was good
better than a gourmet corn dog with
bullet sauce
yeah
it's good it's the sauce it's sweet and
I like soy sauce I like sweet sauce okay
there's one pizza left okay honey
here you go honey yeah it just seems to
be cooked this isn't cooked yeah I mean
no this is salmonella here's the deal we
gotta cook this baby
melted cheese would have been good no
but it's not this is a raw this is pizza
sushi I'm not gonna be picky
you know what I mean assistant cooked
that sauce is good though this is where
the Delta variant began if you cook a
Lunchable you are a bougie I brought
these uh giant long lollipops so that uh
Tammy could show us how to give blow
jobs well I just showed you
we did you with the big wiener I did see
that I did you know what I've actually
I've blocked that out because it was so
intimidating and it made me feel like
I'm less of a woman you're not how hard
can you suck on them the ball I don't
suck hard but I put them all in my mouth
okay okay
I'm sucking on the ball yep yep yep yeah
both of them you know what I mean yeah I
don't just give it a lick okay no
they're in my mouth okay one at a time
the whole sack depending on how big
those balls are
um do you like big balls
can you lie
well I mean you have low balls right
maybe but maybe I'm shallow because when
guys are like I don't like low titties
I'm like maybe I'm just a shell as a guy
that doesn't like natural titties I
don't know I'm not I don't like the the
stubble to exfoliate my chin that makes
sense no it makes sense I don't like it
to mess up my face yeah yeah and then
because I just look like I have leprosy
let's just say I've never had a pair of
balls that I'm like holy shit those are
too big they've all been pretty much the
same I feel like I'm sure
shaved yeah what shaved everything
yeah but if it's a little hair I'm not
gonna freak out but if it's like you
know if he hadn't take care of himself
at all I get fucking mad it's rude thank
you it honestly is rude yeah do you like
pubic hair up on up top if it's trimmed
but if it's just good it can't be it
can't be
um
uh hard stubble
chafing against your face how am I going
to get on my Sally Hansen self tanner
the next day exactly the scalp yeah yeah
exactly fucks up the self-tanning game
but I love sucking dick I'm gonna be
honest with you okay it's probably my
favorite thing to do sexually why
she's the hard work they call it a job
for a reason here's the deal okay now
there's difference I don't like doing it
from start to finish if I have to get
them off that's what pages that's a
whole nother thing okay but if I'm just
sucking it for for months it's not like
there's it's not results oriented right
it's I'm just into it if I'm sucking on
a little bit before I climb on top I
love it just to get it good and and if
he's really squirming
it gets me going if you know what I mean
if he's trying to get away if I don't I
think he's trying to get away he's
really really enjoying it that's gonna
get me off okay it's gonna help me but
you go straight to the back of the
throat or do you do a little no I do a
little I I I get it all wet start with
the tip get a little way a little deeper
a little deeper to where I'm completely
you know
eventually just deepthroat sobbing
crying yeah okay and the and the tears
that come out of your eyes is that for
the lube or is that the oh sorry I just
scratched one of my Sparkles off my face
by accident I don't cry I'm sorry I
don't cry during blow jobs you've never
but in general you do
every once in a while when's the last
time you cried
I watched a Golden Girls episode uh
while sucking dicks I watched The Golden
Retriever get murdered no and uh onion
yeah yeah the Arthur will get you yeah
she's good
um but no I I'm not a crier but I will
get even if I even if I'm not really
gagging I'll pretend I'm gagging sure
sure sure sure
because like I said earlier they love it
they love it they love it and then uh
your go-to television program and our uh
your men allowed to watch porn
I'm sorry that you're not in
yeah
you don't have any boundaries around
that
I don't think so it gives him ideas for
her show
that's true has there been a new move
introduced recently because now you're
getting famous you're on only Tammy you
have a podcast coming out soon right uh
you're we hope so I don't think I'm
allowed to say what else is going on
um you're very famous on Instagram
everybody knows you Luke Bryan's heard
of you how about that Luke Bryan's had
you at his home yeah he made me a steak
you're how was it it was great are you
sure he made me a steak in a baked
potato and he he made my plate and I
said no I'll make my own place no no no
no no no no no no no I'll make your
plate he goes you won't he was flirting
he's a nice dude baby yeah walk me
through this so let's say this is a
wiener winner okay for those of y'all
listening and if you are I'm pity you
this is a uh circusy lollipop get your
get spit in your mouth right now as
we're talking as you're getting ready
really just get it
you know what I'm talking about make the
juice box trip okay yep start with the
tip
get it wet
but get it up in there
my eyes open and closed a lot of you
guys like you to look them in their eyes
I like doing that too really yeah
it's almost like too much no it's almost
like when you want to be nobody else in
the room I don't I'm just like I'm just
like trying to act out like a music
video or something like I have to go
somewhere else yeah I don't have to look
you in the eyes I look up in the eyes
I'm like gosh am I a porn star
you know like am I beautiful yeah like I
like it yeah should I do this for a
living I'm like is this my job
what about direction do you like getting
direction do you like a lot of orders I
have a girlfriend that when she first
sucks guy's dick she goes do you like
teeth or no teeth I was like
because it feels like a vagina
um it feels like a vagina I know you
just bullied me for that yeah it goes
straight to the back that way you can
never give a bad blow job if it goes
straight to the back of your neck yeah I
like to work my way out to tease okay
I'm tired do you do the through the
underwear stuff first like you do all
that
what no like when you start through
someone's underwear and you like you
know people like kiss the outside the
underwear I
I would love to know your definition of
cheating
is it sex is it emotional cheating is it
kissing well I don't know if you're
meeting if you're meeting someone and
raw dogging that's probably cheap not
ideal it's not ideal right it's not
ideal right don't love it but if you're
meeting someone and not raw dogging are
you a good time
I mean that's up for are you stick in
the mud
maybe a little bit of both I don't know
I would like to move on do we have
another delivery here
we have another it's your birthday honey
I'm gonna open up this milk and yogurt
flavored Benton keeps putting
okay this is my audition for Tammy ready
yeah that's my other audition
whoa a face full of whip cream you're
hard
you're hard
yes to come the
sold
look at it
the eyes
holy shit what happened with the eyes
she's taking a Facebook for a while
before to come best tip for deep
throating
just man up and do it man the fuck up
man
don't look over there you put your thumb
on your fist and then you tighten it you
don't you don't have a gag reflex
anymore
okay try it ready I have heard that
squeeze it you just squeeze it tight
weird
the games oh the little
okay A little no give the dude over you
it stops you open your hand now okay
I'll do it again
tight so you put your thumb okay that is
crazy you're gonna tell me that who my
dentist
for real your dentist is a hoe yeah you
know what told me that Dr Dre Dr Dre
told me that wait really doctor yeah we
go to the dentist you can do that
that is actually really weird one time I
was about to sneeze and my new lover who
I'd only have for like three weeks walk
up to me and started hitting me in the
forehead I was like beautiful brown and
Pharaoh call him and it made me stop
sneezing if you're about to sneeze and
you hit someone on your face you can
also do this look this way and you're
gonna sneeze
sneeze no I fucking hate it when someone
ruins my sneeze because I like something
it feels good you know what else feels
good pooping I love it I know
yeah you don't love pooping I love it
Benton you are really just I love
Jessica what you don't love it oh no I
was just looking over here because I'm
just thinking like what I sometimes hold
my poop an uncomfortable amount of time
because it feels better I think it feels
good to hold and poop anyway
holding in poop and then once you let it
go your morning starts
yeah
could never have never
as soon as I wake up
more Fireball last will last before
cupcakes and treats okay mukbang close
your eyes ready and open
this is the best freshest
sushi in the world and I noticed that
that Tammy doesn't
it's not a fan
[Applause]
that smells like that's pussy lips
I thought you spread your legs in front
of me
and it's just sugar fish it smells like
a live fish
yeah that's what my twat smells like it
really does so what I like the fried
shrimp Sushi yo raw dog I bet you won't
fried shrimp Sushi you mean shrimp
shrimp to Pork yeah okay what if you
chased it with some apple pie or some
peaches and cream soda or with some real
stressing calipico strawberry drink or
did you have some of this you know that
okay this is called a milk refreshing
milk and yogurt flavor carbonated drink
did you have this bench
how are you ever going to scissor with a
woman if you can't that's why I'm
thinking I can't I don't smell like that
oh what do you got baby it's that for me
what's that it's the albacore for me
it's the elbow it's a rawness for me
Tammy had sugar fish on her Instagram
where a lot of majestic things happen
Cheesecake Factory we hear the orders we
got a lot of information watched her eat
sugar Fish sushi didn't go so well well
a lot of people tell me Tammy you really
gotta try sugar fish because that's like
the good that's like you're gonna love
it and I was like you know what let me
give it a try I don't like raw so she
would let me give it a try so I tried it
maybe a month or two ago
made me so fucking mad okay uh oh I did
I don't think I remembered the like it
was Israel it was just fishing okay did
you put any soy sauce on it honey soy
sauce I did but nothing else no nothing
else I don't like ginger two like spicy
how how are you with wasabi
I don't think I've ever tried it
well this is an epic moment in podcasts
in there I see uh if you want a church
the lemons go on top of that should we
snort the Wasabi if you want to no no no
no no no please don't do that or put it
on your pussy don't put it anywhere near
well let me try a middle one first let
me use my way what if we put some Wasabi
on each one okay and if you don't like
this it's fine okay you're straight and
that's fine guess what I can use these
okay you're using Chop look at that
Elegance you're ready for the big time
okay here we go
foreign
stressed out I've ever been
no no what if I put what if I put the
grenade on your pussy at the same time
what if I what if I do this oh what if I
do
nothing here's the thing tell me
tell me
um
the the meat was too much the texture
what is that I don't like it what do you
mean did you try it I do not like that
I've tried it raw fish you do not do you
don't need any fish ever nothing try the
middle one here okay that is crab which
honestly is not my thank you Mama
favorite here's a four I love that one I
it's very impressive that you can use it
I use a fork for sushi what's the
texture would you say it's hard to it
tastes like a placenta yeah yeah it
tastes like uh if you if you cut some of
your flesh if I ate one of my clots I
only really do salmon full disclosure I
was clowning you on the sugar fisting
but I really only do salmon I like this
one the Yellow Tail one okay and you put
nothing on it I don't need to because
it's so sweet fish oh Jesus that's what
I'm trying now but I just put a little
piece of meat on there a fish okay yeah
a little minnow
yeah
what kind of fish was that did you put
any sauce on it slow sauce okay wasabi
that's doable because it's very little
yeah but y'all's meat pieces are too big
and they're like flapping it's a texture
that's the new slogan for Sugarfish it's
doable
that is no no that's tuna you gotta put
some on it
it's like Pages pussy you got to put a
little of the pineapple Lube on it okay
to make it tolerable Cherry lip balm or
the Cherry lip balm
do not use the black uh uh label
chapstick the medical kind that just
doesn't work all right they will leave
Wasabi okay Wasabi tuna let's see
foreign
it's not a ball pan not Rainforest Cafe
ooh Rainforest Cafe
that was no I don't have eight at the
rain I think this is if you're trying to
avoid fries do Wasabi almost tastes like
uh horseradish yeah yeah in a good way
right yeah this is if you're trying to
do a lean meal you know what if you're
gonna have tushy sex later you want to
eat this um it cleans out your
she's like I don't know nothing about
sex if you eat this
well I do know I know nothing about it I
do know a lot of things about how to you
right on your body so if you're gonna
have you know you're gonna have anal sex
like you just know what's gonna happen
you just got to do smoothies during the
day um juices yeah you can't just go
crazy on the beef stroganoff in The
Cordon Bleu you're not into it number
one hands down come to your head number
one food thai food okay what's your
order Tom cost soup with a side of rice
I don't get it okay Tammy number one we
just bust open in coconut you don't want
any of it
well I don't know if I could pick I'm
number one last meal on Earth I love a
big breakfast the fans want to know a
what Grand Slam what are we doing
pancakes eggs pancakes biscuits and
gravy what kind of gravy chip beef or
sausage
oh
sausage sausage gravy have you ever had
chocolate gravy I hate it oh that's too
much
it's hurtful it's so delicious okay we
have thank you Grace we have a
microwaved hot chicken sandwich
Nashville you've had honey bees right oh
okay this ain't that give me that baby
just to be clear because fans are are
Tammy mukbang fans refreshing milk and
yogurt flavor uh carbonated drink is a
hard pass
carbonated milk you asked what cum
tastes like that's what comes yeah it
wasn't great but it you know it was a
little sour it's powdered skim milk
citric acid and yogurt flavored
biscuit batter Bisquick
it's kind of hard to get off that tastes
like E coli do you need sauce let me try
this but it looks all dry to me I'm
nervous I'm nervous the coleslaw has
sauce on there do you want any sauces
only in California would they put
coleslaw on a hot sandwich what is that
offensive it's called fall coleslaw yeah
but it evens out the temperature so you
don't burn your mouth no and it gives it
a little Tang I love coleslaw but is it
closer but then it warms up it's a
coleslaw gold we call it coleslaw so we
can't talk how are we doing over there
it's hot wait
also hard chicken comes on White Bread
you only have certain sides that's what
it is that has spicy mayo on it now you
got we want Hardy boost yeah okay stop
talking about that how is it forget
about honeybees every system you can't
you can't so it's good except compared
to honey bees in Nashville that's pretty
good tastes like Paige's asshole
oh no
you guys were having trying to have a
really awkward very silent silent in
your whisper I just dropped my sandwich
where did we land on facial hair and
pull the microphone tiny bit closer to
you either like full facial hair or none
I don't like the mid I don't like the
goatee the either have a full beard
that's got to fight about this I I like
the Scruff okay that's the Scruff all
over like the whole everywhere there'd
be a beard have you ever had rug burn on
your upper lip
not ideal
yeah just what's ideal facial hair is to
me a full beard so long I think it
starts getting soft or nothing at all
and I feel like I'm made a mistake a
little league game wait how long is that
it when it gets long like maybe this one
is longer than my beard
see yours is soft no every guys is
different but yours is this is so soft
this is perfect yeah
you want the tickle you have great
facial hair incredible
yeah I mean it's not the Bittersweet
bittersweet it's not the face that makes
me come so I don't really care I'm sorry
don't kiss me one more time
how often are you kissing your man when
he's not in prison after how many how
many years he kisses a lot and we were
talking about this on the way up here it
fucking gets on my nerves it's a lot
when he's walking across the room I know
he's coming over there to kiss me and if
you piss me off I know it's like I don't
need mouth to mouth I'm good I'm alive
and I feel bad because you know I know a
lot of people don't get kisses you know
and plan on kissing any of us
oh if you oh I'll I'll kiss whoever if
we donate to that only Tammy exactly
patreon only patreon at Vanderbilt
members he kisses a lot it's too much
it's too much you know what's weird
when you look at that porn that porn
made for women by women it's a lot of
kissing there's something hot about it I
gotta say consensual kissing which I
have yet to experience is there's
something hot about watching it oh okay
kissing during sex is different though
do you ever watch amateur porn oh do you
like when people breathe in your face
during sex fuck no no no no
what do you mean when you can hear it no
you know when people get to go in the
mic yeah that's why you move your head
off I'm just trying to not drown I just
like to get fucked you guys y'all are
too picky what is like the main if
you're gonna have a sex toy link number
one two three blindfold butt plug
um I like the I like the time so what do
we think
what do we think about spanking because
when a guy spanks me I know I'm supposed
to be like ow but I'm secretly like
trying not to laugh I kind of like it
okay and do you like a
or a no just a little because sometimes
guys like to do this where it's like a
slap but then they go it's like a
boomerang song I Like Us I like a I like
us okay here's the deal okay I like a
lot of talk I know you said you like
quiet sex I'm the opposite you just need
to record it I want to be I want to be
Tammy is recording a podcast why would
you like dirty talk oh yeah oh yeah
that's the move okay give me some dirty
talk Benson no I'm not giving you dirty
talk okay like subscribe
subscribe like subscribe comment below I
like dirty talk and I like them they
dirty talk what do you like but is there
ever a time where Dirty Talk crosses the
line and you're like okay I feel like we
didn't agree on that I don't feel like
that's ever happened really have you
ever had a guy uh call you a pig no well
there we go I have yeah people love to
call people pigs now huh
people go from like oh yeah this to okay
little pig you're like what are you
doing and you're like too far no I've
never had that happen Okay well mine's
always been just normal and stuff like
what just you know
not that just just like the dirty talk
for you now is like yeah those checks
are clearing bitch yeah yeah you know
like a normal do you like sexting do you
like a dirty text message I don't sext I
don't know because you can't really talk
like oh your sister was this you felt
like this
what stuff like that huh just the normal
stuff you said well and here's my thing
men don't normally moan it's
unattractive and last they're yelling
Batman a lot of them are into growling
have you noticed that it's like you're
like why are you going
is moaning and telling me it feels good
that'll get me off really fast really
fast if that is hot isn't it why is that
so hot and they don't ever moan or they
just are all silent so I'm trying to get
like come on do you do music or no
because I kind of like the noises
but the promise the noise is now are
mostly my knees and ankles kind of
popping do you like being called names
you like humiliation all that stuff uh
maybe like what like humiliation you
know like if they're like oh you little
dirty slut or you dumb bitch you know
what you call me little I think I would
like that but I'll never get called that
it just doesn't happen hey they're
scared yeah yeah I agree but I'd like it
I feel like like aggressive
but what would be over the line
I'm not into the daddy stuff no no thank
you
call me daddy a little girl sweet so I'm
sorry I am big I'm very big and I own
the house that we're doing sitting in
the mouth oh that's gross to me it
depends on the guy yeah it depends and
it depends and it depends on this is an
open mic or no thank you it's a
headliner absolutely yeah you are
welcome here and it depends on the spit
and it depends on the amount of spit and
the way he does it if he grabs her head
and does it it's hot if he's like trying
to find your mouth and it's like yeah if
you playing whack-a-mole and then misses
you gotta nail it you gotta get nail the
three free throw yep agree if you miss
it I lose respect for you and I'm gonna
DM Channing Tatum free say again
number one whole pass page
Justin Bieber
she's obsessed okay look I have a couple
birthday presents for you Tammy one of
them is our auditions for your only fans
and I am I am optioning myself off to be
and one of your only fans videos I just
have to cover my nipples and the top of
my vagina where the line stops I'd love
to have that okay I'm available Cameo
okay or not behind the scenes I'd love
to have that okay creatively I'm happy
to I will pitch my own ideas I'm coming
with brilliant ideas okay it's happening
do you have room for an arc really are
you threatened Paige
Nas I'm gonna film it okay I have a
couple more questions I gotta ask tips
for deep throating you did it Tammy
would you rather have Daryl shave the
beard or the skull it the Scarlet okay
explain the scholar for those that don't
know
well he's not growing hair on the top of
his head that stopped growing and but
where where are we on implants Propecia
no two patches keep it natural why you
know because I think he looks good with
a skull it or bald I'm into a bald is so
hot I think so especially
it's like a prison thing uh-huh
um the skull if you don't know what
skull it is it's he stopped he stopped
growing hair on the top of his head but
he still grows in the back so it's kind
of like a mullet except you know there's
no hair up top the skulls sure sure so
it's called a skull it which I love I
love tugging on it I love you know
running my fingers through conditioning
it I'd rather have the beard more than
anything more than anything and is that
because of uh going down on you thing or
just it's aesthetically beautiful I just
love the way it looks love it love it
because it hides most of his face
exactly that's right
exactly okay we're now taking a break uh
in our alcoholic spiral with trailer
trash Tammy this is me sober on a
different day so just buckle up I'm
cogent my I can read like it or not
everyone on this team except Grace
would be what my OB GYN would describe
as advanced maternal age I'm triggered
so sometimes we need help keeping up
with the latest Tick Tock Trends we
gotta feel it be young gotta be young
that's why okay I'm Benton and I I'm
going to teach you an amazing Tick Tock
dance okay big Trend right now and at
the same time we're going to show
everyone how amazing our sponsorship
station is whilst connecting with Gen Z
did ship station approve this
um we don't know okay so you're a visual
person you didn't get their uh their
response in your AOL address
no it's done it uh now I know you're a
visual person you're creative thank you
you make TV okay I'm gonna play it for
you so you see it okay okay this is a
this is the trench okay okay and we're
gonna do this after we watch this okay
you're gonna follow along okay this is
just we need to connect to a younger
audience and I'm gonna do what they do
on the tick tocks got it are we
connecting okay here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
okay okay okay that was so easy okay how
is this how is this not mocking deaf
people
because none of that was sign language
okay we don't know so you want me to
just do that no while I'm sorry Benton
will show you okay all right you pound
your fist okay I got it
this is clap up now okay so here we're
gonna bend it and then I say something
about ship station yeah but I say it
when I move well ship station will
appear in the air for you in post but
we're also going to say it for our audio
experience okay I'm gonna point I just
don't understand where ship station
comes in because we have to talk about
we love ship station we have to talk
about all the things we like about it
okay okay here I'll show you do I write
on my hands
[Music]
you can import orders from any sales
Channel ship with any carrier using
shipstation's deeply discounted rates
and automate just about any shipping
task Emily hold on a hundred thousand
online sellers choose fictitious so many
sellers
is this supposed to okay so but okay I
thought you're putting it on then the
copy over the video why are you saying
no we are because I'm saying it because
we're a podcast just for our audio I'm
saying it because we're a podcast I'm
just saying it because Ah that's a
slogan
ship station funneled all our orders
into one simple interface that you can
manage from anywhere even from your cell
phone well I should say should small
businesses can now access the same rate
usually reserved for Fortune 500
companies without contracts or
commitments
um I want to say you guys are pointing
at the air but you're really just using
your fist but I think you want me to
point to the air well we don't know if
we timed the words out of the music okay
okay
you get access to amazing discounts with
major carriers including UPS FedEx and
UPS USPS easily compare carriers and
choose the best solution every time it's
too long for the music there's not
enough music that's the problem yeah
that's the only problem this part's easy
okay okay well look Grace can you come
here great can we just get it we need to
we need a walking fetus so Grace oh
sorry excuse me I'm so sorry I don't
know what I'm sorry I'm sitting at your
desk I'm sorry what's wrong we need your
help she's gonna read off this prompter
because she knows everything ship more
in less time for a lot less money just
use our offers
just use our offer code Whitney to get a
60-day free trial
stress free shipping just go to
shipstation.com click on the microphone
at the top of the page and type in
Whitney that's shiftstation.com enter
offer code Wendy makeshift hold on you
were very according doing two things at
once so no more excuses that you can't
text and drive
that's fair I will not take that lie
from you again makeshift happen she's
yelling ship that was good now we need a
chance to bring back a mood who can move
decorum to the show with how do you
pronounce it
trailer trash damn it yeah we'll have a
proper English tea now where's the the
old green oh didn't he get canceled
um I'm sorry your majesty uh we only
have coarse pure because this is all we
drink around here it's a refreshingly
simple beer it's got organic barley yeah
organic hops hopes yeah Hoops
yeah it has water it has water okay yeah
gold come on cool no it's this is sexy
beer this is fancy beer this is beer fit
for equipment I guess I should pivot now
since I am the host and we'll pull the
because pure and here we are let's pick
it up with a little pinky do you mind if
I just do it from the pan can we oh I'm
gonna do the can too this is America
yeah okay here we go I got it hold on
I'll be ready yes
uh
wait okay hold it with two fingers I did
have my fingers separated everybody
drinks here we go okay do we cheers well
we can say cheers
to decorations
yeah here we go
of course that's delicious
of course that's refreshing of course oh
for a good cause pure cool that is that
is fresh that is refreshing now we will
discuss Pleasant topic shall we that
seems standard I'm sure let's have a
civilized conversation your majesty
Queen did you know that this that RT is
only 92 calories and zero sugars and
it's the perfect crisp refreshing
beverage to reach for while you're
living a balanced lifestyle yeah that's
lovely Benton spit pot
core is pure it's organic but chill
about it coarse pear is the perfect beer
to celebrate the Winds of everyday life
so when you want to enjoy a beer without
the guilt reach for Coors pure it's
organic but it's chill about it Go to
corespure.com Whitney to see where you
can find chorus pure you can definitely
find it at our studio I think we have
all of it so we've opened a course pure
store in our studio celebrate
responsibly Coors Brewing Company Albany
Georgia
how do you say Albany Albany Albany
Albany Albany yes Albany Georgia yes
yeah have you ever been to Georgia yeah
why would they want to is there
something I should know about it no no I
just I don't I don't think you'd drive
there do they have cool beer there they
do of course lots of course beautiful
Don't Panic it's organic
here we go bottoms up now back to
trailer trash Tammy where we are trashed
are you ever like I don't want to fart
in your husband's mouth
no you know we for on our focus group
she has a training oh really it's about
mindset and it's all about the mindset
where can we watch that
it's just private on only Tammy so it's
all on only Tammy so we can pay to watch
you lead a group as a entrepreneur yep I
got lots of stuff on there for Tammy
talk and how are we doing on the only
fans are we allowed to say you're on
only fans I'm not really paranoid yeah I
think so but you feel like you've had
promoting it people have been threatened
by your content and prowess everybody
well lost people are shook but I don't
care Barney through it cardi b d you're
being Shadow banned or you're being it's
been that way since before only Tammy
I'm calling it only Tammy just to not
say only fans but wouldn't they want us
to promote their product or service well
Zuckerberg doesn't
interesting he doesn't like only fans
why not
shook I think he shook because you can
make money off that
okay right but I don't know you know
what I mean so we're gonna plug in the
only fans Emily's gonna help me if she's
not uh doesn't have fetal alcohol
syndrome by now we all made a mistake
celebrating this a little too early I'm
gonna call it well we're having shots as
soon as I walked in it was a bad idea
yeah walk me through the opening of this
video okay as someone that spent I mean
days playing this over and over again
okay
that's how I start my videos I just um
it's almost like my it's like a ways but
with your neck of energy to get focused
let's see how it started right right
being like the God is sending you the
vibration I do that right before I say
hey guys Tammy here Tammy here
so walk me through when you make the
thumbnails halfway through is that do
people understand that
oh yeah people get that they get it they
totally get what you're doing and when
you want the thumbnail what is about the
thumbnails you want people to be
scrolling and pick yours okay you tend
to look a little horrified by the meal
well if I'm sitting here like this
okay
people are going to keep trolling
yeah but if they're scrolling and I do
this
yeah they're gonna think whoa what she's
so excited about
what's in that oh and you're going to
click on it I think they just see your
mouth and they start photoshopping it
and doing deep fakes and putting your
butt have you had your body put on porn
stars yet I'm sorry your face yeah yeah
I'm done isn't your face already on a
porn star body that's well there you go
what do you do before you show their
tits is there an exfoliation thing is
there an oiling up I do a little bit of
oil if I'm if I'm posing for the
calendar okay but normal what kind of
oil
I use bio oil
I have baby oil bio oil bio
dude bio oil it's like an orange it's
German
it's for stretch marks it's expensive
yes but some Rite Aids you can get it it
is one of my favorites
excellent It's like 11 a jar how did you
discover that
I just hit a I think I just ate a beef
uh-oh out of this chicken I think there
was a beak in there someone just sent me
sent me a bottle and then I just been
hooked ever since that was it that was
it so that's your
when you go do shoot a calendar do you
get intimidated are you in who's your
inspiration are you thinking like I'll
tell you a certain person I'll tell you
who my inspiration is tell me
last year's me
do you ever think about doing a calendar
with your whole team
people have been asking for that you
know we may do something in the works
you know but I like for it to be me talk
to me about only Tammy on only fans okay
and about my Ark
so my only fans
um I call it only Tammy okay then I have
a week well I post a lot of stuff on
there but you know you're not going to
see me sucking dick on there so don't
get so excited no but I do post a weekly
show called Tammy bangs where I um
basically run a porn Empire yep Paige is
the reception she's the reception who
answers Tanya both phones and I can't
post this on you know Facebook or
Instagram or YouTube because it does
show nudity it does show you know
banging it's very emotional abuse it's
very rated R okay
and um so I'll post it on there and
people love it people love Tammy Banks
all right it's as simple as that they
look forward to it every week there we
are there we are Emily will you sign me
in please since you're the one with the
only fan uh fans account that is always
looking up
our girl here yeah so we are on only
Tammy uh only fans.com trailer trash
Tammy and I am in heaven here that's my
titty that is your titty you're
squeezing it in a very violent way well
did you injure it that's just the way it
looks I'm fucking choking a baby yeah it
does yeah it does it does that's wearing
a tinfoil hat like a mini conspiracy
theory baby I like my only fans to be
different okay
you know what I mean I don't want to be
the same like everybody if someone is
coming to your only fans and they're
like you know I'm gonna spend money on
that second picture swipe over
I don't even know
oh one of my favorite chick talkers okay
what are you going for you're like I'm
gonna give you a different experience
that anyone else has on only fans right
well because when you think only fans
you think oh I'm going to get on there
and Tammy's going to be fingering
herself which would be fine you have
time but look there I am been over
getting my asshole waxed okay I could
never post that picture to Instagram but
how tan you are no not the takeaway so
how did it go was this the first time
you've been waxed oh no I'll wax my
butthole all the time how often
as soon as it gets hairy do you think it
matters though that's for me I want to
thank you for this because I one time
brought up being on all fours when you
get your asshole waxed and somebody said
I was lying about it's wild well you can
just lay flat when I go to the go get it
done professionally they have me on my
back with my legs up and I hate it
really are they always thinking that's
by the way that is a crime that's not
how they make music how do you do it
where are you going
the Hair Cuttery parking lot you're
There and Everywhere okay so when I've
got my asshole bleach you lay flat they
they spread your cheeks a tiny bit they
put the wax on it's over
my balls
yeah yeah I've never had you can do that
laying down on your stomach hold like a
little coin purse yes you can do that
laying down there's no reason you should
be doggy styling your it's easier it's
way easier it's easier okay what's also
illegal but we'll just illegal for who's
the only one there in the world but
being on all fours that's a very intense
way to get your asshole waxed there are
easier ways but I'm with you to me
that's the most but your buttholes
spread the most so they can get a a
better a better you know one of those
I've had my asshole lasered me too okay
so do you know laser what I had a
lasered five times over three years for
the hair on my body it takes forever I
know I'm still going for something but
if your hair is dark it hits harder yeah
if you have light skin and dark hair
well sometimes a couple strands go in
like yeah like Smithers okay I get a
couple that come in and I just gotta
shave again towards the grain I gotta
follow it and sometimes I'll tweeze it I
love the smoothness my uh lover shaved
my pubes for the first time last night
whoa did you get up in there the
crevices and everything no he just did
the top he was pretty it was pretty um
it was a slap Dash job he uh Bert
Chrysler had talked about it he said
that the key to his relationship with
Leanne was he uh shaves her uh uh
crevice every couple times every month
whoa yep number one fantasy you'd like
to live out
besides the threesome I think I was
about to say triple pin sure
three dicks yeah you know you will see
uh on only Tammy on only fans you will
see her tits at all velocities at all
longitudes and all latitudes well that's
me jumping into a pool sure and
um my tits are going they're flying up
yes they are going you know sure like
flying saucers so yeah it looks like
ghosts are punching them yeah they like
ghosts yeah and that's a real picture
and that was completely candid nothing
photoshopped on all the time not
Photoshop that's right that and that was
completely candid I didn't even know
that picture was taken no stretch marks
on your tits I do but they're they're
real a lot in color okay they're healed
you know since I was fucking six years
old are these your boobs yeah on the
side oh those are very pointy yeah you
can't really see them like what size
boots are you oh I've never had a
measured a you don't have a uh do you
wear bras no you've never had a bra
I have but didn't like sports bra yeah I
don't need them and they look cute
because your nipples are very high I
think nipples showing through a shirt's
cute I know but you can't go to a job
interview well thank you I mean this is
an unbelievable page there's me trying
to queef okay I'm gonna go this one I
would I didn't do it but I'm gonna go
the next one down it says me trying to
queef this is you you just asked me
and I said yeah I can't but I literally
haven't done it in years like I probably
haven't we I haven't forced myself to
queef and
15 years
so I'm gonna be embarrassed if I can't
but I'm going to attempt to queef
for the first time I'm gonna please like
fucking if that's different like to make
yourself queef it's been a long time
I'm gonna take my pants off just because
you're good airflow or something like
that you know what I mean yeah so yeah
just a little just a little blow no it's
a little low and I got a bend down
I'm nervous I'm kind of scared Jeff what
are you feeling give me a second let's
send this to Clayton
dude give me a second but it's hard
pussy muscles forgot how to do it dude
hold on hold on hold on okay hold on
what's the key pull open the lips
here we go
give me a second okay maybe it's nerves
you really gotta work your stomach
muscles just go oh yeah
God damn watch this
give me a second
then your face is bright red
are you okay on demand yeah 15 years I
love that streaming service
here we go
hold on give me a second
why won't the air go in
the air will not go pussy too tight put
your legs close to your head pussy too
tight it'll happen give me a minute too
many kegels
too much collagen
don't tear
s hold on
there's a little bit of air there but
not enough to make a full queef
squeeze we don't want to take his pants
all the way off it's hard
this is only Tammy
you have a tampon who's got a tampon is
everyone trying to queeze
hold on everyone's trying to clean okay
give me something everyone's like
praying are you also praying
man I usually do this man I used to quit
every day I used to go
like nothing like took a second why is
it taking so long
this is just like ourselves right later
in life your pussy starts to fall what
happened give me a second fall it
changes that's for sure it changes gets
it gets longer just ask him quack
um I'm like out of breath you are wind
y holy cow
I've never been more frustrated in my
life
and why am I out of breath
because you just suffocated yourself
you didn't get your core on that one
baby
it's hard to do that was out of the
asshole not the pussy
oh my gosh
can we show that
listen guys listen
I promise I promise I'm making to my
subscribers
I promise you
I will work on this
and I will give you a queef I will get
this quote for you by show of hands in
the comments
who wants to see me queef
where are we on this journey
well that was the first that was the
first video I did I need to do another
one trying to quit again yeah so how are
we working on it are we doing kegels are
we practicing putting balloons in there
I'm gonna be honest with you I haven't
thought twice about it what if I send
you home with this what do you think
someone just Puffs the mirror in there
first by the way I love that you just
pulled the hair right off it and didn't
think twice no
no oh I need to do I need a chocolate
honest to God used to I could queef like
nothing just queef okay you gotta do it
now I can't do it how are you what what
do you what do you you just saying you
just suck up air and then just what
happened too much success I knew it
maybe how do I get the money I hate the
money got me what are the main am I
allowed to ask this I don't want to fuck
with an artist process because we talked
to some magicians the other day and I
was like tell me how you did no
what's like the number one ritual for
like I'm damn it it's the hair yeah I
cannot be Tanny without this hair and
what do you put in there Crisco no
that's just natural I don't wash it all
the time love it oh and then no it's
just it's just the mannerism she always
looks like something stinks
I always picture Tammy based off of I
always picture her in a um uh uh
bodybuilding competition that's always
what it is
um no one in particular but I did take
the mannerisms from uh Charlie's Theron
and Monster
the hair the slickback hair no way like
her like you know kind of mean you two
need to do like a dead show or like a
little short
where Eileen warnos meets her match oh
my God yeah that's where I kind of took
if you watch that movie back you'll be
like uh-huh uh-huh yep
but in terms of like her personality and
the content it's just a mixture of
growing up in Oklahoma yep and seeing
just I have family in Tulsa mm-hmm
yeah
that's my people just Tammy Tammy uh
where are you
where are you are you going to church
weekly where are you with god well you
know I'm going to heaven is that if
that's what you're asking no clearly you
you create heaven for dicks all over the
nation you know I'm a good person and I
have a good heart yes correct
um do I go to church every week no
it ain't about the physical church it's
about if you pray or not
what's a prayer should we all pray
together
[Music]
what prayer did you do as a kid I'll
leave you some prayer hold on what was
the prayer we did dear God Lord in
heaven heaven be thy name thy kingdom
come thy will thy will be done I know
what has the finished do I remember we
didn't do that uh thy will be done on
Earth as it is as Earth as it is in
heaven still don't understand what that
we did that when we played basketball in
the shadows yeah okay we never did that
one do you remember the pledge of
allegiance to the flag of the United
States of America
this is gonna get a cliff somewhere
let's see what you got and there as it
is heaven yeah amen thy kingdom come thy
will be done
right
and then what's the main prayer Hail
Mary full of grace I never heard that
one okay okay we always just did
something like dear Lord bless this food
to our bodies and the hands that
prepared it amen amen thank you for
these food and these people that's what
we do yeah oh I had a whole thing I had
to memorize so not Catholic Christian
yeah there's a difference yeah okay I
think that around stressing's hitting me
hard oh are you okay you got a shit
really I think I can get a yes oh no
what you're not gonna Yak you're not
gonna puke did you have sushi and ranch
dressing soda
oh my God oh my God she's gonna be
called up here someone give her
something give her a hot sauce give her
a bag just give her a um like a like a
like a diva cup oh no
you drank that are you always dressing
like five hours ago
it's just starting to hit there's what
made her sick
what's in that ranch dressing soda by
Lester I mean his name's Lester look at
least the other one was Melba
ingredients spring water cane sugar
roofies natural flavor Ester gum
oh no the Ester gum will get you Paige
are you okay do you know Tums I ordered
Tums for you you okay honey take it I
don't think I have Pepto what are you
chewing why are you chewing gum oh I do
that's my Pepto don't touch it but we
have Tums
yeah good did you just pound a bunch of
Pepto okay good good good you look
better oh
feel better
getting my meat sweats or something
the meat sweats we can't hear you you
have to either talk into a microphone or
not that's a good one you can't wear a
Justin Bieber shirt and not no
microphones
which I'm saying do you want to come in
here
come on Honeys okay come on you want
some more Sushi yeah
do you want some of the uh do you want
some Lunchables yeah do you want some of
the salsa from the Lunchables yeah so
wait did you puke from the ranch
dressing and the Fireball mix oh I'm not
quite sure if it was the bacon the
peanut butter and jelly or the jelly
Sprite the Cheetos and then I
not sure just was sitting here yeah
let's say our bucket list goals for our
life because it's going to happen yeah
bucket list you're going last okay Paige
bucket list besides getting out of here
without completely uh dying dying yeah
um
fuck bucket list place you want to
travel thing you want to do when the
show's done filming I want to go to
Egypt okay
don't and Rule yeah okay don't go well
it's just a little hectic right now
aren't there some problems there
it's all dusty well fuck right now I'd
just rather chill here what do you want
to do look at the pyramids
oh there's one in Vegas oh that one is
beautiful the wind is gorgeous I love
this let's go there and see if that
scratches The Edge yeah I've gone it it
almost is air conditioned oh you're
right I do what's your dream Tammy you
know what I want to do I want to do some
traveling and I'd like to go somewhere
that is just
amazing and beautiful and somewhere
really far and really expensive
somewhere maybe like Florida
I'm going to clear water in the fall
the beaches are supposed to be beautiful
and they keep the scientologists in the
building I'd love to go
I'd love to go I'll think about it I
want to go to Florida
and that's really it I you know I just
always dream about that I want to travel
I want to go where'd you go on your
honeymoon baby we went to uh Branson
Missouri come on
we did it up big sure yeah and where'd
you go Hotel yeah we stayed at the uh
Ramada sure in inside of it got it yeah
got it kind of got it was that one of
the plazas uh I don't know about that oh
shit dude they have plazas now really I
didn't know about that never Ramada
Plaza whoa never heard about that maybe
when you renew your vows yeah we have to
let you go at some point okay I just
love you so much girl are you guys gonna
stay with us no we're gonna oh no we're
gonna watch the ring camera live but we
Are Gonna Leave You we we stocked it
with lots of
thank you delicious vittles Ranch drinks
tons of ranch no more of that um
no it gave Paige coven and then uh some
government cheese oh that's all you need
it is trailer trash Tammy it is Paige
the great legend that is Paige I'm sorry
this went on so long but this has been a
dream I'm also here
Denton would you like to sign off
for us yeah go ahead hi I'm Benton the
coast of this podcast and I would like
to tell you not to ride elephants don't
ride elephants have a great night thank
you guys
seriously and these very awkwardly and
you know it we love you guys only Tammy
chelseielynn.com get the calendar got
the boob shirts uh they're probably
already sold out we love you we love you
[Music]
oh
we're clear what can I get you baby I
feel awful
uh I'm good
did you walk I don't know
you you are yeah
sure yeah sure are there any allergies
you needed to tell me about before the
mukbang yes sir I have this one oh it's
the ranch it was the ranch soda the
ranch butter
foreign
I feel horrible it's my fault though no
I'll keep that I'll keep that track
I'm good
I'll keep that trash right outside the
bed
yeah yeah he's good here hey Honey's not
good here hey honey it's puke here hey
honey sorry about your house here
hey Honey's puking all over Whitney's
house Whitney's beautiful
uh porn uh Castle yes hey honey it's
nice to meet you here hey honey oh honey
what's up I've never seen you sick very
nice anemic here hey honey something go
on hey honey emergency room here are we
going to the free clinic what are we
doing hey honey we're going to our
Urgent Care here okay we're going to
urgent care here baby dude what was it I
just got like sweaty and just it keeps
coming out could it have been the hot
dogs the sauerkraut the sushi the
possibly kind of old coconut milk
potatoes I think yeah the Cheetos did it
that's supposed to make everything right
it makes them all laugh the Tito's in
the ranch drink curdled there's also a
bacon drink
I think it might have been the bacon
drink or the key lime drink the bacon
drink we also ate Lube oh the lube and
we should be going why is she doing what
happened we ate four different types of
lube honey
I don't know why I'm sick we're all
naming off
ranch dressing soda bacon Lube Twinkies
cakes
sauerkraut sour uh beans
cheese neon cheese cheese flavor
Lunchables we had Lunchables as well we
had a pizza I told you that wasn't
cooked you never listen to me you should
have cooked it I told you it was not
cooked that was a raw Pizza that was
pizza Sushi and I was right we should
have cooked the Lunchables you also
watched me deep throat a banana that
made me a fact that
what about that lollipop there was a
oh my God lollipop did you have any
um what is it called wild thing Wild
Kratt no
and then the fireball did you have a
fireball baby
Honeys it got you how much Cheetos did
you I didn't see that I wouldn't miss
that she had a couple shots of Tina
oh in an empty stomach not for it and
that ate all that shit so here I am just
just kind of you should have had the
ribbon from the birthday cake
fucked up okay you'll be okay honey
thanks honey I'll be okay okay I can't
wait till you fall asleep so I can shave
your pussy
better not it's an added down hey we
gotta do something at least sell it or
something maybe just cornrows cornrow it
give it to cancer patients
of love for me yeah I will get that
website
I don't think it pays though baby
don't send it there